all right good morning everyone
and I assume we're online so I'll just
remind everyone that uh that uh live
Mike and can be a bad mic if you're not
paying attention so okay
um so uh we're gonna open it up this is
uh the first hour here we're gonna try
to get some energy uh everybody
introduce themselves and uh of course
I've just uh put everybody in uh
shuffled the uh the chairs here and uh
so I guess
why don't we start over to the left
representative Walsh why don't you
introduce yourself tell us a little bit
about you don't have to be
yeah
I'm Lily Walsh I'm from Hampstead New
Hampshire and my background was in the
computer industry for companies such as
Wayne labs and Hewlett Packard
and primarily focusing with
semiconductors and I've retired and now
I'm doing this
awesome
okay represent a spider
it's beer okay now he has the red light
needs to be on
sorry that's all right we're all
learning
I've been a techie for 53 years and I
still don't know how to work buttons
uh military Aerospace for 53 years and
then I retired and I spent the last 20
years traveling around the world uh
filming endangered species uh I used to
own my own uh
I guess we call it a tech company in
military Aerospace
okay
good morning everyone my name is Susan
Porcelli I represent Rockingham District
19 which is Hampton Falls in Kensington
I was a senior executive at Fidelity
Investments for quite a long time on The
Brokerage platform so my specialty is
trading and I understand that Financial
Services is one of the most heavily
regulated industries that we have so I'm
very familiar with some of the rules and
regulations regarding that industry I'm
very excited and interested to be on
this committee so I can understand a
little bit more about some of the
banking and insurance and interestingly
enough alcohol issues
funny how they combine banking insurance
and alcohol
and I look forward to working
cooperatively with everyone and I
appreciate the great opportunity and I'm
for obviously from my white card I'm a
first time rep
perfect
good morning everybody I'm Meryl Gibbs I
represent Concord Ward 9 and again
obviously I'm a newly elected rep
um I've lived in Concord since
um 1984
and I'm retired I had a career of 38
years in civil rights law enforcement
for State I was director of the New
Hampshire commission for human rights
and then moved over to the federal
government and I worked for 29 years in
the office of fair housing and equal
opportunity of the U.S Department of
Housing and Urban Development and most
of the time I was a manager of the unit
that handled
the requirements for civil rights
regulations for HUD grantees so I
retired in 2016 and then this year I was
asked to run for the house and so here I
am and I look forward to working with
all of you
excellent
I'm Karen Calabro Hillsboro District 45
the towns of Greenville Mason Brookline
and Hollis I was horrified to discover
this year that I've had 40 Years of food
service experience
I am a physician associate today but I
am still very active in this industry I
am an administrator on New Hampshire
eats I do a lot of travel around the
state and around New England promoting
small businesses small places I'm trying
to expand agritourism in my area I'm
building a network of people in Southern
New Hampshire if anybody wants to help
me
um to try and expand this really unique
industry to help stabilize small
families and people who are trying to um
improve their economic stability
I'm also really
um excited to be starting with my
husband and developing
um in the area we are trying to build
small time small homes for first-time
homebuyers and for retirees with a low
carbon footprint my husband is an
architect AIA I do know business code
quite well so in building code
I'm really excited to be part of this
this is actually one of the Committees I
asked to be on I feel that I can help
contribute I am very bipartisan I will
not look at a d or an R after a bill at
all so I'm going to look at it at the
Merit of a bill being a good bill
thank you
good morning I'm Lisa post and this is
my second term
in the redistricting I now have I Now
cover
lineborough and New Boston and Mount
Vernon
I have a very varied background from
banking to I worked in the White House
under the Reagan Administration I was an
educator
and uh
uh
a business owner a self-business owner
and
um I have uh
been on the resources research and
development committee uh which I found
very interesting but I came here to uh
uh have a hearing on a bill for a
constituent and I listened to many
people before me and many people after
me as I stayed here to listen and I
thought Commerce is a really interesting
place to be and a lot of my background
touches on all these different sectors
and I was also a human resource
assistant so that brings insurance and
benefits and all those types of things
together for me as well so I am looking
forward to working with everybody here
and I appreciate the opportunity to be
here and again I I will uh just say I
will Echo
um the
um
Echo the fact that
I will not look at whether it is a
Democrat bill or a Republican bill I
think we all need to work together I
think that's what our constituents want
now and
um I am looking forward to being very
productive in this committee thank you
great representative Herbert
I'm Manchester Ward four
um
former stock broker print journalist
um owner of an advertising agency and a
republican for 30 years
I'm a Democrat now and uh this is my
Administrative Assistant
John keeps me organized anyway Nick
welcome to Commerce because it's uh
I think the best best committee to be on
yep I gotta keep him organized uh
representative John potusik from
Rockingham 13 which is Derry
just playing Derry there's 10 of us uh
this is my fourth term
uh I've done a lot of things in my life
I think my resume has like eight
different careers so far this is number
eight uh I love being on Commerce uh
is very interesting I get to know some
wonderful people work with some great
people
uh including the chair
and uh
I'm looking forward to this year because
I had the opportunity to work more
together with some of my friends who sit
on the opposite side of the aisle and
get a lot more done this year
so looking forward to it and thank you
Mr chair
my name is Jane bolier I'm from
Manchester
um
this is my ninth term in the house I've
served on four different committees
um
and my
past is very past I owned um
small several small businesses for 20
years and I've been on several local
boards School Board a few years ago and
uh I really have learned an awful lot in
the house and look forward to plurking
for this committee thank you
so I am John Hunt I have uh was first
elected in 1986.
my very first term was Science and
Technology because uh the time Harold
Burns thought that uh that committee
should get involved in computer
technology and I was an apple IBM dealer
at the time
um that again is my past life in terms
of computer retail in more present time
yes I have been serving on this
committee ever since then except I did
have one brief term where I was given a
a reprieve from Commerce if you want to
call that but I I was sent off to the
Hindu lands called legislative
and and uh actually Paul Smith was my
clerk back way back then so in this more
recent is you will uh the rumor is true
I do live in a castle and uh and yes it
is true that you can rent it at eighteen
hundred dollars a night plus the
wonderful New Hampshire meals tax
so I do have some interested in vacation
rental issues having said that I would
say that this committee when I first got
on it it was uh actually the history of
the community was just Banks it was
Banks and then
by the time I got here was Insurance
um I think George russos was just left
being Deputy Deputy insurance
commissioner at the time and and uh so
um
it was you know kind of a boring
committee but the reason why I wanted to
get on Commerce Way Back Then it was
Interstate banking issue and and they
seemed like they had ever receptions
every week and and that was a real odd
issue every lobbyist was registered on
one side or the other and I said well
this is that's a committee that's got
some exciting things happening there
um but then uh my my tenure is that I
made it even more exciting and that is
uh later in not so much later but I um I
passed the uniform trust code uh and uh
and then the speakers then decide that
all the trust legislation shouldn't go
to Judiciary it should come to Commerce
because uh clearly I knew something
about trust as someone who has some and
then uh the was uh direct shipping a
bank a bill a liquor I was in the beer
of the month club and I was being cut
off by ups and I said what do you mean
you know well we don't think we don't
think it's legal to deliver to you and I
said well show me the law well there was
no law but we made sure there was a law
and so once we uh got direct shipping
and then um I also did self-distribute
for beer distributors all of a sudden
they decided that we uh Commerce should
get all the liquor bills and that's why
we have them here and so I I take a lot
of responsibility for why all these
different issues that you will see come
to this committee
um
in theory you know the Commerce is
almost everything you know Commerce can
be anything but uh they're obviously
there are other committees have a little
more focus on whatever type of issues
they have so we are sort of a catch-all
um the most famous bill that got me uh
moving up the ladder was indoor smoking
I was the one who wrote changed the law
and indoor smoking from uh you know
looking for non-smoking to turn it out
to New Hampshire was you can only go
smoke in designated uh smoking areas and
uh so since then I've uh have served as
chair starting took me took me five
terms before I finally got to be a chair
there was a lot of people here who just
hung around long enough that they had
more seniority but then since then I
have chaired and then I have been the
ranking minority most of the time so uh
I am open to always new suggestions new
ideas but it is true that a former
lobbyist once said that I was Carmen the
Magnificent that I will I will give you
the answer before I even heard the
question that that some people would say
that you can oh you'll once you get to
know me you'll get to say is you'll
pretty much know where I stand on almost
any issues simply because I've been
doing this for so long that I'm pretty
consistent and I and I do pride myself
on being consistent so
with that
thank you my name is Keith Ammon this is
my fourth term and Lisa post and I share
a district it's Hillsborough 42. so that
again is New Boston Mount Vernon and
lineborough
I was Clerk of this committee last term
so I learned a lot writing a lot of
notes before that I was on Science and
Tech Municipal and County so I had a
little bit of a varied experience in my
early 20s I got some exposure to
corporate finance that didn't last very
long I went into a pharmaceutical
I.T development and so that's what most
of my career has been spent on so uh
developing projects that have to do with
a lot of data
uh about 10 years ago I got interested
in blockchain so I was on the governor's
blockchain commission that just wrapped
up in December so we'll have some things
to talk about with that
my wife has worked for I think four
different insurance companies and I have
a life insurance policy with each one I
think that's her master plan
um
so uh at least I have an expert at home
when I need to have an insurance
question I look forward to working with
everyone on the committee and we see a
lot of new faces and looking forward to
get getting to know everyone thank you
foreign
hi everybody I'm Anita Burroughs this is
my third term I started out in judiciary
I really enjoy being on Commerce I'm
glad to be back I I've had a varied I've
done various things in my career I was
in high tech for many years focusing on
marketing and operations and
um I had a catering company for a number
of years and I now work my husband for a
national Healthcare consulting company
that is was um started by my husband so
I work for my husband
um let's see what else I can tell you
I'm just I'm really glad that we're
equal in this committee I think it's
going to really change the Dynamics here
I think we'll work closely together to
get a lot of good work done and I'm
really glad that we're alternating so
that we get to know people from there
yeah I just have to say I just noticed
uh how all women on one side and Men on
the other so I am going to I will be
shuffling shuffling the seats so we're
not we're not locked into this
configuration because this is no good
okay okay still better so um let's see
what else I was going to say yeah I mean
I think it's going to be a really good
year I'm looking forward to it and I
guess the only other thing is
um I'm the ranking minority leader so uh
Dems caucus it in case I don't get to
say it caucus at whenever we break here
upstairs it's either in 403 404 or 405
we'll figure it out
okay
John I hadn't noticed uh I'm sorry when
I came in I was going to sit with the uh
with the women
but I did I didn't recognize that you
had actually set up the room in such a
way and that was a mistake so I'm glad
that I'm where I'm supposed to be now
thank you you'll get to stay there yes
it just decides yeah the Freshman I have
to sort uh Paul Terry I am a second term
rep from Alton and Barnstead in Belknap
County this is my second term on
Commerce as a freshman I did not select
Commerce in consumer affairs as my as my
first choice it was my third choice but
that was a mistake because this is the
model house committee and I can say that
with a great degree of knowledge and
confidence having been here for for two
years
so it's good to be back on a Commerce
and consumer affairs and that I was not
um
uh traded to another committee shall we
say
I really learned a lot the first two
years and it was really enjoyable
this past December I celebrated my 45th
anniversary
as an ordained minister of word and
Sacrament in one of the country's oldest
and largest Protestant denominations
um I am officially honorably retired
from active service although from time
to time I still have an opportunity to
uh to perform some ministerial duties
uh it's a good thing that I'm on
Commerce and consumer affairs because I
really am acquainted with a number of
the areas of of concern that have been
assigned to this particular committee
because during my term of uh of actors
or the years of active Service as a
minister I served in a Presbytery where
I was on several terms the chair of the
Board of Trustees and also the president
of the corporation and we dealt with a
lot of the same matters actually that we
deal with here on Commerce and consumer
affairs
accepting the Liquor Commission well we
did we didn't do any liquor uh in in the
church but um not officially that is we
had no regulatory authority over liquor
and so anyway great to be here uh thank
you for those of you that I'm
recognizing nice to see you again and
look forward to meeting a number of you
new folks as we move forward during the
next two years thank you
uh good morning everybody my name is
Chris McAleer I'm from Carroll County
District 2. I live in Jackson uh
representative Burroughs is also from
Carroll County uh District Two uh in
Jackson I'm on the planning board in the
Board of Trustees prior to that I spent
uh about 45 years in the financial
services uh industry various insurance
and securities license actually I had a
stint at the federal Fidelity at one
time so uh and and also with
representative Herbert he was at Merrill
Lynch and uh uh I called on him when he
was at Merrill Lynch so a couple of
firms there I currently have my real
estate license
um but unfortunately real estate is not
doing very well so luckily I have this
gig to help me pay the bills uh prior to
that
um I got an economics degree from the
University of Pennsylvania and one of my
classmates you might have heard of them
was a a former president so well that's
my little uh claim to fame so to speak
but thank you uh this my second term
second time on the Commerce Committee
and this was the only committee I put in
the four different choices so uh I like
it here thank you
good morning my name is Kenneth Vincent
I serve District 12 which is Somersworth
in Rollinsford this is my fourth term I
came from science technology and energy
and if you want to test your ability as
a state representative serve six years
on that committee
um I uh retired in 2015. I did 33 years
as a firefighter a lieutenant and uh
Chief fire investigator for the city of
Somersworth
um I'm looking forward to be I'm
definitely looking forward to being here
change of pace uh science was very
challenging
um I'm currently a city councilor in my
third term for the city of Somersworth
uh and I'm really happy to be here thank
you
I'm Brian Cole from Manchester New
Hampshire Hillsboro 26. I own a
wholesale import company we sell tools
to retails throughout the United States
I have a big Warehouse in Manchester
it's about 3 000 items so it's pretty
extensive uh the ambulance company for
the city of Manchester is also my tenant
so I'm pretty familiar with leases and
that kind of stuff and I look worked
forward to working with all of you I
think we got a lot done thank you
my name is Sean filio I'm from Cheshire
district 7 which covers Keane's Ward 2.
I'm an attorney trained in Securities
and Consumer Protection Law and
currently work for a law firm which
specializes in plaintiff side derivative
actions uh prior to that I was a Federal
Judicial law Clerk and the U.S District
Court for the District of Massachusetts
under judge William young where I worked
on a range of cases from patented
trademark infringement to Securities
cases so have heard it all and looking
forward to being on this committee which
seems like it's going to be hearing it
all thank you
my name is Nick Thaxton I'm from Troy
that is Cheshire 12. I represent Troy
and Fitzwilliam
in a 45-year business career
that I have been in insurance
working at the corporate level
money Mortgage Banking the building
business and for the last 33 years in uh
the Monadnock region is a reasonably
successful real estate broker uh I'm
licensed to sell real estate in the
state of New Hampshire Vermont in the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts
I have a degree in economics and I had
three kids
several of whom I liked
hi yeah my name is Jared Sullivan I'm a
freshman this year is my first year
obviously
um this I'm glad to be here I have a
degree in economics a grad degree in
economics I've been an economist my
whole life I primarily have focused in
real estate economics I'm
proud to say I'm one of the nation's
leading experts on uh warehouses the
warehouse industry pretty exciting stuff
um but so I do I do some Consulting on
that outside of here since this job as
lucrative as it is doesn't pay quite
enough to survive so I I do some I do
some Consulting right now I'm working on
a employment analysis for San Antonio
that's the project I'm working on right
now so uh yeah that's me
great thank you all
and we're almost ready at the time yeah
so just a couple things
um as you probably noticed there's a lot
of folks here visiting us and all of
these people will you will get to uh to
know because each one of them is someone
who uh will Lobby this committee on
various different issues and I I in past
years I used to schedule a time for it
um but uh but it will as time goes I'll
I'll let them speak so but but since
we're we have the insurance department
here I probably will start right in with
the insurance department and then
afterwards those those lobbyists who
represent different Insurance Industries
I'll invite them to speak or introduce
themselves
um so as you probably all noticed that
some phones went off and this committee
is the committee that created the five
dollar rule and
um I'm I'm cutting the slack today
because you know you can't tell somebody
a rule until after the after they had an
opportunity to be told about it uh we
used to have a sign it would say right
it'd be up front there if you know if
your if your cell phone goes off
um you owe five dollars to the coffee
fund so my recommendation to you all is
that when you walk in the building and
you sign in for mileage then you pull
your phone out and put it on silent and
that way if you get into that habit you
will not have to pay the five dollars
no I I understand that you know we we
all have our first day
[Laughter]
okay so we start off with the New
Hampshire insurance department and uh I
would say that we uh this is the
insurance committee uh we do all
Insurance except workers comp
workers comp is for the labor committee
and uh but I have been invited every
once in a while to participate in
workers comp issues mainly because
usually the speaker appointed appointed
forgot that I don't do workers comp but
uh but that might be helpful in it but
otherwise
um good morning
Mr chairman uh Cameron Hunt thank you
for commissioner excuse me it's uh so
nice to be back in person uh it wasn't
the same two years ago doing it over uh
WebEx but I'm glad to be here I'm joined
by DJ Bettencourt my Deputy Commissioner
uh behind me on the right is Heather
Silverstein our general counsel and on
the left uh Sarah Giroux who's our
legislative director uh you'll over the
session you'll meet up probably another
five or six staff members from the
Department we'll get to the end of the
slide deck you'll see all their contact
information but we've passed out our
slide deck
foreign
thank you I'm sorry you couldn't hear me
uh do you want me to start over
sure my name is Christopher nicolopolis
I'm the commissioner for the New
Hampshire insurance department I'm
joined by uh Deputy Commissioner DJ
Bettencourt general counsel Heather
Silverstein and our legislative director
Sarah Giroux over this session you'll
probably meet five or six other members
of our department at the end of the
slide deck you'll have contact
information for all of our
Representatives we also passed around my
business card that has both my direct
dial Office phone number my email and my
cell phone feel free to use those when
you need to talk to somebody from the
Department about any insurance issue
the slide deck will roughly approximate
What DJ and I are going to talk about
today first off the mission of the
insurance department uh is to promote
good by ensuring the existence of a
state safe and competitive Insurance
Marketplace and we do that through the
development and enforcement of New
Hampshire insurance laws
and we're committed to doing that in an
honest effective and timely manner a
little bit of background about me my
name is Chris I've been commissioner
since February of 2020 so just to go
back and think back to the week before
covid shutdowns happened and that's when
I took the helm at the insurance
department it's been an interesting 30
odd months
prior to spending prior to being
nominated as insurance commissioner I
spent five years as the president and
CEO of a Statewide trade Association for
Independent Insurance Agents New
Hampshire Association of insurance
agents and prior to that I spent most of
my career and the private practice of
law including some legislative work here
the New Hampshire Church department has
85 full-time staff positions as of today
75 odd of those are filled and we're
always looking to fill the the holes in
the department
um but it's natural in this time to have
some openings uh New Hampshire
Department was established back in 1851
in fact it was the first state insurance
department in the nation we have that
distinction
and the statutes that we uh that we
regulate run from RSA 400 through RSA
420 Q
um besides uh regulating the insurance
industry we're also responsible for
collecting premium taxes fees and the
regulation of insurance companies
producers uh and adjusters last year
2022 the New Hampshire insurance
department collected general fund
revenue of
154 million nine hundred thousand
dollars
135 million of that came from the
premium tax which is a sales tax on
insurance policies uh 20 million of that
came primarily from licensing fees for
the uh folks licensed here in New
Hampshire there's some administrative
fines probably about a plus or minus uh
one one million dollars
uh the New Hampshire Insurance
Department's administrative costs are
covered by an administrative assessment
on New Hampshire licensed insurance
companies and so there's no general fund
a revenue that goes to support the
insurance department the industries that
we regulate pay for us
in New Hampshire there are nearly 200
000 Insurance licensees and that's
because
um anybody no matter where they are in
the nation uh working for a National
Insurance Company if they're going to
potentially have an interaction with a
New Hampshire consumer either to deal
with a claim or to deal with the sale of
a policy they must have a license and so
though there are probably seven or eight
thousand licensees that are domestic
that live here in New Hampshire and sell
insurance to our members uh the other 96
percent are in other states they're
Manning call centers where we hear our
daily tv ads on you know in 15 minutes
you can save 15 or more those folks so
it's nearly 200 000 licensees that we
administer here on our team and believe
it or not only three staff members
manage the renewals of all of those
people almost 20 million dollars in
state revenue
other things that we do at the
department is we provide Financial
examinations of every licensed insurance
company license in New Hampshire and
ultimately what we're looking for is to
ensure that those companies remain
solvent that they're charging enough
premium to pay the claims that they're
committed to paying that they have
enough in reserves and adequate reserves
so that they can continue to meet their
obligations
each each every five years we go through
a financial analysis review from the
NAIC DJ I'll talk about that in a minute
to ensure that our team is doing that
adequately we've passed with flying
colors uh the last two versions
our department also conducts Market
conduct exams for regulated entities and
some of those are targeted you know we
have a Consumer complaint that gets us
curious about whether or not a company's
complying with our law and we'll send
our investigators in to look
specifically at a potential violation of
New Hampshire law and other ones are are
just random that we go in and make sure
they're complying with our claim
settlement Practices Act we go and look
at 100 or so claim files and determine
if they're meeting both our state laws
uh federal laws and are being fair to
Consumers
we have a team that investigates and
prosecutes insurance fraud we have an
enforcement we have an enforcement
division of three folks that ensures
that our license sees those 200
000 licensees are complying with our
state law our disclosing required
information about
potential criminal acts against them
consumer complaints against them so that
um so that we know that those folks that
are holding a New Hampshire insurance
license are uh are fit for that
distinction
I think DJ's going to talk about some of
our more exciting uh divisions consumer
and uh and legislative and then I'll
wrap up and we'll answer questions thank
you
thank you commissioner thank you Mr
chairman good morning to the members of
the committee uh as the commissioner
mentioned my name is DJ Bettencourt I
have the pleasure of serving as the
Deputy Commissioner of the insurance
department I would note that in a
previous life I sat on your side of the
table here and I will say that I was
always much more comfortable being where
you are than where I am uh but I will
certainly do my best
the mission of the insurance department
really does rise and set on consumer
protection we have a dedicated team of
seven people
who the entirety of their day is spent
working with consumers who have had an
issue come up
we receive approximately 5 000 calls a
year into the department the good news
is is that two-thirds of those calls are
people who are simply looking for
information they are people who
um unfortunately have had something
unfortunate occur they've got to go to
the doctor they've been in a car
accident they're trying to locate a life
insurance policy and so now they're
going through their policy they're in a
moment of stress and they're trying to
understand what all of these technical
terms mean for them
and so we're a resource for that uh you
know the other quarter of the complaints
that come in do turn into formal
investigations the company has
mishandled a claim or has engaged in
some other activity that is not
consistent with New Hampshire law and in
those cases as the commissioner
mentioned we have resources to go into
not only address the issue that the
consumer is going through but ensuring
that that issue is not part of a broader
Trend within that company
so we're very very proud of that team
just last week we put out a press
release that captured some of the
accomplishments of our consumer Division
and I won't go through it all but I do
want to brag on them just a little bit
so during 2022 the consumer services
unit processed
929 Consumer complaint investigations
over 4 000 assistant requests and 90
applications for external Health review
and what that equals in terms of
consumer recovery is that we collected
an unprecedented 4.1 million dollars for
New Hampshire consumers which eclipse
the 2021 recovery by over 2.8 million
dollars so obviously that is real money
by any measure and we're very proud that
we performed that service for granite
Staters the only thing that we ask
consumers have to have helped them is to
Simply tell other people that we are
here that we are a resource and that we
are available to help them so as you are
traveling throughout your districts if
you have a constituent that's having an
issue as the commissioner mentioned
please give us a call we have a team
that can Dive Right In and try to get to
it in as timely a manner as humanly
possible
additionally as the commissioner
mentioned earlier we do provide
expertise we are a resource to the
legislature as the commissioner
mentioned we have a team of
approximately three to five people that
you'll see here on a consistent basis
our approach is that we defer to our
subject matter experts when coming to
testify before the legislature it's not
going to be just the Chris and DJ show
you may see us from time to time but we
have bona fide subject matter experts
throughout our department that Focus
specifically
in particular areas of insurance and so
whatever legislation is coming before
you you should have confidence that the
individual who's testifying on behalf of
this department is an expert and they
know what they're talking about and if
they can't give you the answer that
you're looking for immediately they will
get it to you in very very short order
Sarah is the enforcer over there she's
another resource for you but she makes
sure that we are on the straight and
narrow
uh as the commissioner mentioned we
collect premium taxes when we do have an
issue where an enforcement action must
be taken we handle the penalties and
fees that go into the general fund
we also participate in the National
Association of insurance Commissioners
or NAIC
to kind of summarize NAIC it's important
to remember that throughout the history
of our country insurance regulation has
been predominantly a state function and
we're very very proud of that in the
NAIC is a group of the 50 state
Commissioners as well as seven eight
territories
seven territories uh and we work as a
team we work as a team uh for a number
of different reasons
in the first instance they make tools
available to us that ensure 50 state
coordination in things like what's going
on in the industry so we have a
state-based system by which when we have
a Consumer complaint come in it goes
into that system it allows us to track
to see if there's a particular Trend in
New Hampshire but more importantly it
also sees if there is a trend going on
throughout the country or in other
states and so this way there we can say
okay
uh is this particular company just
missing the ball in a New Hampshire
issue or is this a corporate level
decision that seems to be running a foul
of a number of different states uh
regulations and in in those instances
where it is a broader Trend we have
resources within our uh counterparts
throughout the country to call them and
say do you have a better idea of what's
going on here how have you handled this
what approach did you take to help these
companies come into compliance with our
regulations
the other big highlight for neic is that
we get together and we develop model
laws to promote consistency from state
to state it's a business friendly
approach we understand that for
companies it can be a real challenge to
get to know each of the 50 states
particular nuances within its laws and
we of course have our unique features in
New Hampshire law but we do try to make
that as uniform as we possibly can again
for ease of use for not only the
companies but also for the consumers
themselves
um as I mentioned we'll be providing
subject matter expertise to you I've
covered that slide
and so I think with that I'll turn it
back over to the commissioner thank you
it's first day back I'll get used to the
microphone uh in New Hampshire it's a
couple important facts for you to
appreciate and understand we have 57
domestic insurance companies that means
those are companies that are licensed
here is New Hampshire being their
primary home for those companies we take
a we take the lead in all the financial
and compliance reviews making sure that
their financial adequacies uh financial
statements are adequate
uh there are also
1131 other companies of foreign
companies uh licensed to sell insurance
here those are domesticated somewhere
else in the nation
we do uh ongoing Financial exams of all
those companies every five years if
they're doing business in New Hampshire
we participate in the financial review
where they are
teams a couple of the divisions that we
didn't talk about is on both our life
and health side and our PNC side we have
folks that review each and every filing
and so that looks like you know when you
get your homeowners policy in the mail
or your health policy in the mail
somebody on our team has viewed each and
every sentence of those documents to
make sure they comply with New Hampshire
law if if applicable federal law and
that the uh guidance and outlines within
those policies are fair to Consumers and
so we have a team a
if they're not here so I can admit it
the most boring job in our department
that all day long all they do is review
these these forms and we have laws that
govern how most of them should be
drafted and when a policy decision needs
to be made we have a meeting to talk
about what the impacts of a language or
the market changing
oh we do the same thing for every rate
filing when an insurance company files
new rates here in New Hampshire we have
an actuary who will review that uh file
who will look at the assumptions within
that filing we'll look at the factors
that they're using to rate that filing
and determine that they're done in a
non-discriminatory way done in
compliance with our law that both
charges an adequate premium but not
excessive premium you know we don't we
have a you know we have a an interest in
ensuring that companies don't just buy
the market come here and charge a
premium that's lower than they need to
pay claims just to to grow market share
and our team does that uh particularly
well
um
I think there are a couple things that I
just want to follow up on on things that
DJ talked about and he mentioned the 900
consumer complaints that we review each
year I think it's important for you to
understand how important uh those 900
complaints are to DJ and I and so when
our team reviews and processes those
complaints and helps consumers get to an
end result not one of those complaints
can be closed without a meeting where DJ
and I are present to go through what the
facts were what the complaint was the
company's response our interpretation of
the complaint in the company's response
and the final outcome so that we're
ensuring that in every case we have the
best minds and us I won't admit I won't
for a second imagine that we're the best
minds but that we all understand what's
happening in the marketplace and so each
week we go through all of those uh so
that everybody knows that uh what's
happening out there and when there's
something that needs to be fixed then
everybody knows that we're requesting
and demanding that be fixed so nothing
slips through the cracks
I think it's important to understand how
big the insurance Marketplace is in New
Hampshire as compared to the nation in
New Hampshire we write about .4 of a
percent so a little less than half a
percent of the nation's insurance is
written here in New Hampshire I think
it's important to understand that
insurance companies aren't sitting in
New York or in in Hartford saying what
we really need to do is to break into
the New Hampshire Marketplace
uh you know in New Hampshire we've we've
long taken in this committee and the
legislature has long taken a free market
approach to regulating insurance we want
people to sell insurance here in New
Hampshire because it's a good place to
sell insurance a good place to do
business and we do that in in large part
without getting getting into nitty-bitty
regulation on how they do it we have a
super competitive Marketplace here when
you look at our Auto rates they're in
the 10 lowest in the nation despite the
fact that we have nicer than average
cars worse than average weather
um and no mandated auto insurance that's
not an accident that's because of what
you've all chosen to do year in and year
out we could say the same about our
health our individual health plan costs
uh oftentimes when one of the 10 experts
that we talked about uh comes in to
speak to you or to any other legislative
committee they'll start with the
department has no formal opinion on this
bill
and then they'll have 10 talking points
that might sound very much like there's
a lot of concern here or a lot of good
um and we try to understand and
appreciate that you get to make the
policy decision you get to decide if we
want to adopt for New Hampshire a
mandate that might have upward pressure
on premiums
so our team will come in and say this
might have upward pressure on premiums
understand that
um but uh we will we will try not to
make that or to pretend to make that
policy decision for you
um and if you think you need more or
better information from the Department
you let me know
uh and finally I just want to point out
hopefully uh for those of you who see
the consumer service number the
800-852-3416 I highlight that that's
going to get you to the uh
is it seven member seven-member consumer
service team uh for any of your
constituent concerns if you want to come
through djri for those or through Sarah
directly to d uh to Keith and his team
you can do that but the most direct way
is that 800 number
we're happy to answer any questions you
might have
that was great
um I think that I guess in terms of
issues that I want to emphasize is the
um solvency and that that when you think
about why the insurance department was
created way back in 1851 the issue was
always that is we want to make sure that
an insurance company sells an insurance
product is going to be able to pay
if there is a claim being made so people
often would argue when it comes to other
types of insurance like health insurance
like why aren't they holding costs down
why aren't they beating them down you
know on the premium down that we take
the position that it's a competitive
Marketplace and that what's more
important and what their obligation is
is solvency and not not necessarily so
if somebody because you've met somebody
if someone was to come in and offer a
very extreme premium
um you you might caution them but that
at the same time if they really want to
sell that product at that outrageous
price uh and as long as you feel that
there's solvent but you could then say
yes but you know gee you're never going
to sell any of these policies you only
might sell one or two and and then
therefore you might still have a
solvency problem if your premium was too
high chairman hunt that's that's 100
right and New Hampshire hasn't had a
company go insolvent in a generation 90
nine was the last one are you making me
that old uh no I think it's a it's a
testament to the work we're doing uh and
the company that company actually came
to New Hampshire uh home insurance yeah
moved to New Hampshire from somewhere
else but toughs toughs you know we they
theoretically they did have a solvency
issue
and I would just add to that hopefully
this makes you feel a little younger
chairman we're still doing runoff on
that time
is Dave Nichols still doing it is he
still running oh yeah oh yeah no but I
mean it's a very very good point because
when one of these companies uh goes
belly up it is an absolute bear of an
experience and it takes an incredibly
incredibly long time to close this thing
out as the commissioner said the last
one was in 99 they keep telling us that
we're five years away but I've heard
that for the last two years that they
keep saying it's five years so I don't
know when this will actually finish out
but uh it is not uh in any way shape or
form or good thing when one of these
companies becomes insolvent
okay any other questions okay
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
gentlemen for um a very uh comprehensive
uh detailed uh clear and interesting uh
overview of the work of the department
um I'm curious as to
um what issue you would identify as the
one that you're dealing with at this
time
um that you you consider to be the most
difficult issue
what channel and difficult and
challenging issue
I think uh that's a hard that's a great
question it's a hard one to answer one I
didn't anticipate I think
um it's kind of a job interview question
um I think the the one thing that gives
me the most concern is the shift from
State regulated health insurance
products to erisa products erisa
products that aren't regulated at the
state level not regulated by mandates
that you Embrace and not regulated by my
department
and that's because it is the worst
answer I give when I get a call when I
get a call from someone saying I need
help
I need help getting somebody a referral
I need help getting somebody a placement
I need help getting a bill cleaned up
whatever that might look like and it
looks like a lot of different things
when it turns into a self-funded product
my wings are somewhat clipped and so to
me that's probably the thing that I
would like to work on the most
um
I would just add to piggyback onto that
you know and in the course the the
corresponding effect that that shift has
had on New Hampshire's small group
Market
our small group Market has been
shrinking for a number of years now and
obviously that has consequences on our
state's employers and ultimately the
coverage that they can provide to their
employees the other thing that I would
mention
it's a little bit on the lighter side
and the Commissioners touched upon it
and I've touched upon it but I'll hit it
just one more time
and that is letting the public know that
we're we're there
um I sit right outside of um kind of the
the admin who handles most of the
incoming to uh to the commissioner and I
and it drives me crazy that at least
once or twice a week she receives a call
from a consumer looking to buy an
insurance policy from us
um there's just a little bit of a
disconnect there between uh what it is
we do and what it is that they're
they're looking for
and obviously we can't help a consumer
that doesn't know that we exist and that
we are a resource to help them you know
the good news is is that obviously we've
entered a different phase of the
pandemic and it's now allowing us to
re-engage in our Outreach events uh
we're doing a lot of different events a
different uh targeting of of population
groups I'm very excited to say that in
two weeks we're starting our insurance
course at New England college that
obviously is geared toward helping to
train the next generation of insurance
professionals but we're here for the
public and um so to the extent that you
can help us spread that word it would be
deeply appreciated
representative McAleer thank you
chairman hunt uh you mentioned I think
you said something like 4 million in uh
in claims that you uh got refunded from
people I'm interested in how how does
that pan out I mean is there any one
area that is particularly uh uh claim
worthy or uh the one area where you
would see the biggest number would be
say a life insurance claim where we help
uh resolve an issue with uh payment of a
claim so you're going to get a
potentially a 250 or a million dollar a
resolution when when those stand out I
think in large part
um the kind of Lion's Share outside of
that will be a big health insurance
claims you know somebody has a hip uh
replaced while they're out of state in
say Montana they forget to get you know
just making this up as we go they forget
to get pre-auth and the bill comes to
their out-of-state Health insurer who
says wait a minute you told us this was
going to be an inpatient or an
outpatient became an patient and the
Bill gets rejected for lacking a
pre-auth DJ and I spent several weeks on
the call with the commissioner in
Montana with the hospital and with the
health insurer we get it resolved in in
one swoop that might be was it eighty
thousand sixty thousand dollars
and then there are the smallest claim
that we resolved this year
is somebody who had uh insurance premium
monthly insurance premium uh spill sent
to them then it said in the in the
footnote of the pre-printed invoice
three dollars of this premium is for a
paper billing fee
we have that bill this year
well the fact of the matter is that that
was a pre-printed form and that wasn't
in fact part of the 17 premium uh but we
took the position that you're saying
it's for paper billing fee they're not
paper billing and so you have to give
them the three bucks back and so we
spent
an hour in a meeting discussing how
we're going to mandate this company send
the three dollar check back and then
they did
so that's the range I I would say that
one of the things I'm very proud of this
committee have accomplished we'll
briefly touch upon them when we talk
about the consumer protection act but in
the consumer protection act there are
four entities that have an exemption
from the consumer protection act and one
of them is the insurance department and
this committee actually passed the
statute that required restitution by the
insurance department to ensure that
every consumer is made whole
so I would say that that's one of our
our accomplishments when it comes to
this issue
and it works perfectly I think the
department because we have the staff and
the expertise to do it but the other
thing it does is it turns out that there
are occasions where we find companies uh
this year uh 2020 actually one of them
will fall in 22 one of them will fall in
23 but we had a company that was fined
250 000 I paid that and and uh a check
that we I have received but have not
cashed yet for 23 will be a 257 000 and
this is just a company doing something
wrong several hundred times and we said
enough
um
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you both for uh
coming to testify and instruct us
um just as a general uh rule if you
could help us establish one the the
difference between uh the purview of
state government and federal government
you said uh in the beginning of your uh
presentation that it was traditionally
state governments purview but if you
could just give us uh where the
boundaries are so we know what our
Authority can affect
representative uh I appreciate the
question and unfortunately there's
there's no way in the amount of time
that any of us have today is to lay out
all the boundaries I think it's helpful
to understand that the vast majority of
PNC Insurance the kind of car House
business insurance is going to be
regulated entirely here in New Hampshire
uh the carabouts from that are very
small and those would be for for lines
of business that there isn't a ready
market for and I don't think we need to
to think about that today
um the next biggest chunk of uh of
authority that we don't have would be
things related to the AC
so you know uh Obamacare uh things
mandates that come from there uh and
then finally uh uh Orissa and so those
are Arisa is
employer-provided health insurance
um for large companies that will go
across straight lines and therefore
isn't subject to any states regulation
and the other uh big one that I would
highlight is to our great relief we do
not touch Medicare or Medicaid
we do oversee Medicaid Medicare excuse
me supplemental products but if you've
got an issue with Medicare or Medicaid
writ large then you're going to go over
and see our friends at the Department of
Health and Human Services
representative Gibbs
[Music]
so now you want to press the button
thank you uh yes
um
your discussion brought up a question uh
that I'm going to try and
summarize where where this question
comes from and it's something that
actually happened to me personally that
I'm going to use it as an example my
personal issue with insurance has been
resolved so I'm not asking you to
resolve my personal issue but I'm using
it as an example in case something
similar should occur to one of my
constituents
um okay uh I when I retired I retained
my federal employee health insurance uh
federal Blue Cross Blue Shield uh so
when I became eligible for Medicare I
got only part A hospitalization I did
not get Part B
because I was already paying for my
federal uh employee insurance
uh then I had surgery and it I stayed
overnight but apparently technically the
hospital considered it to be outpatient
surgery even though I stayed overnight
the result was that Medicare and Blue
Cross kept passing the bill back and
forth each of them refusing to pay it
and the hospital sending me a bill for
thirty seven thousand dollars
and uh this was eventually resolved uh
because it was technically outpatient
Blue Cross did pay it but if
a constituent were to come to me with
such a question is that something that I
would tell them to call you or the
Department of Health and Human Services
or who could help them with that
I'm going I'm going to go on on a limb
here and say it's always probably
quicker just to say call Chris and DJ
um and if we need to call our friends
over at HHS we're happy to when you're
when you're dealing with combined
services like this uh and when you're
looking at coordination of benefits
typically the reason that those bills
get hung up is because both the uh the
primary insurance and the federal
insurance will have expectations for how
the others bills get delivered and when
those aren't done when the eobs the
explanation of benefits aren't aren't
provided to
uh Blue Cross is liking you'll see that
nothing happens totally in action and so
if you were to call me in that case I
would call my folks at Anthem and say
resolve this and in the day they call me
back and say I just need the EOB and and
we would then call the provider and say
give us the EOB so we can make this go
away but our department would be
absolutely the place to handle those
thank you
um I'm sure you can get close all right
close
um if you turn yours off the speaker
should work oh okay good
um last year the year before
um and for several years there's been a
lot of discussion about Paid Family
Leave
and so I was wondering if there was a
document you could provide us with to
um just help us become more educated on
how
that works sure absolutely the first
thing to note is it's been a wonderful
collaboration between our department the
department of administrative services
and the Department of Employment
Security we've kind of become the Three
Amigos in standing up the state's Paid
Family Leave program there is a lot of
information out there right now
the enrollment for individuals into the
program just opened January 1st the
enrollment period for the business
Community opened I want to save December
15th my understanding is that
preliminary enrollment for the business
Community has been healthy has been
strong so obviously that's very very
encouraging news but there is a lot of
information about the basics of the
program I'll be happy to put a package
together for for the committee to the
extent that you all are interested and
it's an interesting time obviously as
this thing is playing out in in real
time
you're welcome
further question
new question okay
so I don't yield back the balance
gentlemen um you have asked us to assist
us with your Outreach efforts um I'm
thinking back over the course of my
lifetime in the several states where
I've lived
um
State Insurance departments that I'm
thinking of in other states have
Consumer Guides to Insurance in the
state of blank uh just wondering do we
have such a guide is it readily
available on the website and would that
would that not assist us in helping you
with your Outreach efforts to be able to
tell people that they can go to the
state's Insurance website and order a
copy of the consumer guide to Insurance
in New Hampshire do we ever we've got a
consumer document for just about
everything we deal with the only
drawback that I will share with you at
this time is that it is on our website
which is not very good we're going
through the process right now of
rebuilding our website we're joining the
rest of the state agencies in that
process
so for the purposes of this committee it
might be better for me to put a package
together for you along with the
information that I promised to
representative bolio and get it right
over to you so that you have that not
only for your own purposes but also for
for your constituents and in a couple of
months time we're going to have a brand
spanking new website that's going to be
very user friendly and all of those
documents will be in one place so that
when the consumer goes to the website
they know exactly where to find the
information that they need one other
thing I would mention because it kind of
Blends together a couple of different
questions that we've received in terms
of things that worry Us in terms of
where the state and federal
um
a line is and then Medicare one of the
things that we have seen recently is a
an uptick in deceptive and manipulative
marketing practices around Medicare
Advantage
the states used to have the ability to
oversee Medicare Advantage products and
those are separate let me make the
distinction from Medicare supplemental
products we still have authority over
supplementals not Advantage the states
lost Medicare Advantage Marketing
oversight in the early 2000s with the
Medicare modernization Act and the
trouble is that
we're seeing a dynamic play out and it's
not just
um the advertisements that you see on TV
although let me be very clear
um I admire Joe Namath William Shatner
is a phenomenal actor don't get your
medical insurance advice from these
folks please
um but but more seriously and more
prevalent are a third overseas third
party organizations that are making
excessive calls to people and they're
linked up with agents and we're not sure
where yet we've tried to do a little bit
of undercover work and unfortunately one
of our communication staffers got a
little too deep into this investigation
and he started getting so many calls
from these advertisers it nearly
rendered his phone unusable
um and and
by not having control over you know
ensuring that the person you're talking
to wherever they are is licensed because
that's
part of the deal here
and then also understanding what is it
that they're representing to the
consumer what is part of the sales pitch
and when you're talking about a
population that could sometimes be
vulnerable as as the senior population
can be
it is incredibly difficult for us to get
those calls from a senior who has gotten
pulled into some Medicare Advantage plan
and it's just overturned their entire
world and the only
tool at our disposal is to introduce
them to the federal process by which
they can appeal
and the feedback that we get is that
that process is in many cases a black
hole in other cases is incredibly
difficult and slow to work through
so we have asked our federal
counterparts if they would consider
giving States back some of that
Authority and it's an ongoing
conversation
well it really should happen because uh
let's face it advantages only for people
who are over 65 so I mean that's that's
the vulnerable group so it's it's uh it
does do something okay great thank you
very much thank you uh we do have a
little time left so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to introduce some allow
some lobbyists to introduce themselves
um and we're going to begin this by
having a a former member chairman of the
committee uh uh who is not going to
necessarily fits into my other
categories and where who she represents
but Tara why don't you just come up
introduce yourself so you can get back
to work
uh thank you chairman hunt and um hello
to all of the former members and and
welcome to all the new members of the
committee my name is Tara Reardon I
serve seven terms on this committee two
of them as the chair uh back in the
late 90s early 2000s I work for the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund which is a
fund that is a Community Development
Finance Authority and the biggest
program of that fund is a program called
Rock NH and it stands for Resident owned
communities New Hampshire New Hampshire
is a real four in the Forefront of
manufactured housing communities where
the residents have bought the land under
their homes and we have a 145 of them we
have as many as there are nationwide
because it started here it's a really
important source of affordable housing
for the state we've been doing it for 40
years with a lot of success and no
failures to date no nobody sold their
Community back or went bankrupt or
anything like that and we'll come to
your committee because despite all of
the other things that chairman hunt
listed you also um
regulate manufactured housing in
residential communities and investor
owned Parks RSA 205a and 301a and it's
great to meet you all look forward to
working with you thank you chairman
great all right so now we'll do some
insurance lobbies so we'll start out
with Lindsay
oh you would have George okay you let
the boss go first okay let's Applause oh
you want to come together sure
20 minutes yeah correct
and if you do it in two minutes I'll be
upset
to start from dude yeah well no you need
to be the mic because we do have someone
who has a hearing
thank you good morning members of the
committee I'm Lindsay NATO and this is
my partner George russos we are
Attorneys at the Oren Reno Law Firm just
down the street in Concord you will see
us here on a variety of mostly insurance
issues we represent the New Hampshire
Association of domestic insurance
companies as well as the American
Property Casualty Insurance Association
those are both trade organizations for
Property and Casualty companies we also
represent several individual companies
in the area and we also will see you on
health insurance bills as well
did I miss anything oh
but I'd just like to say thank you again
for this opportunity it's uh it's great
to be introduced to the new
representatives and to see those of you
who are returning it's uh always a
pleasure to come before uh house
Commerce I think it is certainly from
our clients perspective the most
important uh Committee in the
legislature as commissioner nicolopoulos
mentioned uh New Hampshire has got a
good a competitive environment for
insurance and that's due largely to the
laws that you have passed and the laws
that you have decided not to pass
which which make it a good environment
for insurance companies to do business
and then the second part of that is the
quality of insurance regulation these
are the things that companies look to uh
when they decide where to do business
and New Hampshire Affairs very well both
in the legislative side of things the
business friendly
Outlook of the state generally and also
the quality of insurance regulation and
a lot of our time is spent uh dealing
with the insurance department
representing our company clients and uh
um they
they play a very important role as I
think was emphasized it's really it's
state regulation apart from health
insurance which is another totally other
uh being
it is this unlike Banking and securities
which are of equal size roughly to the
trillions of dollars in the insurance
business it really is the state
Regulators that have all the authority
again other than health insurance to
regulate uh what insurance companies
practices are so it's a very important
job and we thank you Mr chairman great
so just you know you all know is um we
talked about domestic insurance
companies in foreign
does not mean International form means
other states
domestic is uh uh are regulated here by
the state we have a domestic and George
represents the domestic so if you have a
domestic insurance company problem
don't bother calling Chris DJ just call
George because George
[Laughter]
okay next row uh Mike and
committee my name is Mike McLaughlin I'm
a lawyer talked real close
I'm a lawyer in a lobbyist in Concord
New Hampshire I'm the Regional Council
for Allstate Insurance in New Hampshire
Maine and Vermont I've been wandering
the Halls since 1994. uh started my work
in this in the state senate as a
Legislative Assistant so I've been here
for quite a while working with chairman
hunt and members of the committee
um one thing that the insurance
department emphasized this morning was
their availability and they have been
integral in working with the companies
as well as the consumers and we always
have the opportunity to talk to them
about issues one of the things that
chairman hunt pointed out earlier was
the consumer protection act which you'll
hear from many people how insurance is
segregated out and it's segregated out
because of the work of the Commerce
Committee and the consumer has a media
access to his um a remedy whereas if you
go through the legal channels you end up
in court or paying legal fees and
Recovery is way down the road so when
you look at the work the Commerce
Committee does it's consumer oriented
but it's also business friendly and
business friendly doesn't mean that
consumers are put at a disadvantage the
playing field is equal premium rates are
competitive throughout in New Hampshire
with lowest insurance rates in the
country
we talk about mandatory Insurance every
couple days but this year the bill got
pulled because we don't it was a an
interesting the only com the only state
in the Union does not have compulsory
liability insurance and it works uh it's
counterintuitive we don't want to get
into discussion John but it's a please
not please do not we've done we've done
it every other year for 10 years but I
look forward to working with you uh I'm
available in Concord and thanks for your
service to the state great
oh we do have a question
yes representative it's sort of a
question and maybe a comment I'm not
really sure where it goes
I being a new uh
rep at this I had to spend a lot of time
over the summer knocking on doors I
knocked on almost 1800 doors
and I heard from a lot of people and at
least one lawyer and three or four
constituents that said that New
Hampshire is an insurance State if you
have a problem with insurance and you go
up against the insurance company because
they decide not to pay
you're going to lose
so I know we care about what how
insurance companies are perceived but at
least the constituents and Nashua Ward
3.
think there's some kind of a
disadvantage here and maybe somebody
needs to do some homework
we would hope that uh after you spend
some time on this committee
you'll have be armed and ready to help
educate your constituents but I hope
it's also not true and I don't know that
yet that's true that's what I'm saying
I'm hoping when you've been on this
committee you'll have learned that how
this issue is solved thank you very much
Mike okay so we have two different uh
agents of agents and we have one
representative today so why don't you
come on up and introduce yourself
thank you excuse me thank you Mr
chairman my name is Joan pejao I'm the
president of the New Hampshire
Association of insurance agents our
association represents and has members
of Independent Insurance Agents
throughout the state they have about
230ish offices from Colebrook and North
down to Nashua and South
um I would hope representative that
anybody that has a problem would talk to
their independent agent we have our
office right on governs Falls Road here
in Concord I'm certainly available at
any time to try to help a consumer we
work very closely with the insurance
department and with all of our members
both independent agents and we have
carriers that are also members of ours
to make sure that consumers are properly
covered throughout the state thank you
thank you is there anybody else from
represent the insurance or wants to
weigh in at this moment introduce
themselves
okay oh all right
so I didn't I see you yesterday online
you're doing an energy bill yesterday
yes good morning Mr chairman um I spend
time in sdne too yeah
close to the mic sure
um good morning everyone my name is
Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher Callahan
and gartrell and I represent ahip which
is America's health insurance plans it's
the national trade Association for
health insurance carriers
um here in New Hampshire we have a
number of members
um I'm sure we're going to forget
somebody but um Anthem uh Cigna Harvard
Pilgrim
um centene we have mcos that are members
um
and uh so I'm I'm not an insurance
company but represent the trade
Association they have um Representatives
throughout the country and every state
um I very I look forward to meeting all
of you and working with you
um our overarching goal is to um try to
ensure that uh consumers here in New
Hampshire have affordable
um high quality health care and access
to that affordable high quality health
care so thank you very much
okay thank you oh we do have a question
Heidi
I just have a question I just have a
comment about lobbyists in general uh
many of the new members
um uh may you know put lobbyists put
lobbyists on one side and you know on
the other side but they're here to
educate and they are available
um if there are any questions you have
on you know any bills they've been very
resourceful and uh I just want to you
know give a good plug to the lobbyists
who are also educators
okay
okay so come on
thank you chairman hunt I'm Sabrina
Dunlap I'm director of government
relations at Anthem Blue Cross Blue
Shield and I just want to introduce
myself many of you might know Paula
Rogers who was in this role for over 10
years and thankfully Paula is still
around she's doing some Consulting work
for us and she's wonderful and a wealth
of knowledge but
um anyway Anthem has been in New
Hampshire a very long time and I am
always happy to take calls and questions
whether it's a constituent issue or
you're having an issue whatever it is
um and we are you know part of the
health policy landscape in the state so
always looking to solve problems and be
helpful so and I urge you to send an
email to all the members with your
contact information yes I will
um I would say that that Anthem plays a
very large part part in our health
insurance in the state so she's a very
good person to know when you have a
constituent complaint or constituent
issue yes all right thank you thank you
okay having done that well now we'll go
to banking now Amelia was not able to
make kit and who's here from the banking
Department
uh okay there okay great thank you
they won't come in until insurances left
right
okay great
let me get everybody but Amelia
[Music]
no problem
we enjoyed your grand entrance yes and
then you can introduce yourself come on
up
and and take the microphone and
you have handouts okay
so some reason I thought you weren't
going to be here is that I yeah I missed
that like a okay
I was planning on being here okay good
um
good morning good morning
um for the record my name is Amelia
galderi I'm the bank commissioner for
the State of New Hampshire
um just give it a minute for the handout
to float around here
um make sure I hopefully brought enough
it's okay okay
is that right all right very good you're
good okay
I wasn't sure if I had enough there
um so again my name is Amelia galjeri
I'm the band commissioner for the State
of New Hampshire
um I brought
um a team of folks with me today who I
think are going to be primarily handling
legislation for us
um so I'm going to take a moment and
introduce them all to you and these will
probably be the faces of folks who
you'll most often see here if you have
any questions about banking Department
issues
um I would direct you to these folks or
to myself so
um first um is Bob Lamberti he is our
Deputy general counsel
um Ian Clark is our public information
officer uh Seth Zaraki is our general
counsel Mike moranti hiding in the back
is my my new Deputy
um he uh started about a week ago so
we're happy to have him
um
so
um as you'll see on the handout it
starts with our mission statement so the
banking department is committed to
protecting the Public's interests
through the professional supervision of
the financial services it regulates so
we are primarily a consumer protection
agency I'm tasked with uh
supervising financial institutions
um
what that means in Practical terms is we
have teams of examiners who go out and
examine
banks credit unions Consumer Credit
division licensees for safety and
soundness in their operations as well as
compliance with applicable laws and
rules another primary function of ours
is consumer facing so we take consumer
complaints and investigate them for
allegations of unfair and deceptive
activity or potential unlicensed
activity just to name a few categories
and then another way that we carry out
our mission is through off-site
monitoring all the entities that are
licensed with us are chartered with us
have to submit um quarterly data to us
that we monitor very closely for any
changes any unusual activity that sort
of thing
um so to to carry out that activity
um with regards to the handout
um there's information on here about the
structure of the banking Department
we're divided into five divisions so
first we have con the consumer credit
division the CCD division they oversee
several thousand Consumer Credit
licensees those are comprised of
Mortgage Bankers mortgage brokers
mortgage servicers small loan lenders
title loan lenders money transmitters so
think Western Union PayPal they're
licensed with us debt Adjusters
I think that's all of them
um so that's the consumer credit
division they they oversee those
entities
we have a banking division they're
tasked with overseeing the activities of
17 State Charter Banks and nine State
chartered credit unions
we have the trust supervision division
they oversee the activities of 41
non-depository trust companies and
Family Trust companies so a trust
company is um there they range in
activities for several years now we've
been undertaking efforts to modernize
our trust company laws in New Hampshire
to attract
um a vibrant trust industry and some of
the trust companies are more what you
would consider traditional they oversee
a family's private wealth however
there's also several creative uses for
trust companies that choose to be within
our jurisdiction because of our
modernized laws managing all sorts of
different kind of investment vehicles
and
items like that
um finally so those are the three kind
of subject matter areas that we have
um we also have a legal division that
supports those divisions so the legal
division provides advice to the the
Commissioner's Office the other offices
in the banking department they
investigate consumer complaints and
allegations of unlicensed activity
um they make commence an enforcement
action based on what they find in those
complaints or from referrals from the
exam team and additionally they assist
with legislative efforts so you'll
notice I have a couple of them here with
me today
um and finally we have an Operations
Division that supports the daily
functions of the banking department so
they like pay our bills keep the lights
on et cetera do our budgeting
um and very important stuff
um so all in all we have 48 positions at
the banking department for staff and if
you flip to the back of your handout
it's not on the back of mine but it
should be on the back of yours there's a
org chart
um which is microscopic and I apologize
for that but I just wanted to give you a
sense visually of
what we have at the banking department
for human resources if you have any
questions about that I can provide you
with a digital copy that you might want
to just email this to us so yeah we can
zoom in yeah well actually when you put
it on the screen it's not not too bad so
um but I apologize for that I just
wanted to give you a sense of what we
have at the banking department for human
resources
um so moving right along another
important issue is how the banking
department is funded
um we are a self-funded agency so that
means we're entirely funded by the
businesses that we regulate so
um technically speaking when you see our
budget we are classified as our revenues
are classified as 100 coming from other
sources
so what that means in Practical terms is
at the start of each fiscal year
um we we receive a appropriation from
the state's general fund then over the
course of that fiscal year we take in
examination fees fines penalties
um and apply those towards that
appropriation
and then at the end of the fiscal year
we tally it all up and if there's a
deficit between the amount of fees fines
and penalties we took in and the amount
of the appropriation we invoice our
entities an assessment amount for that
deficit basically
so in a nutshell that's how we're funded
um and um I'm happy to answer any like
if you need to have a question about any
of this at any time just raise your hand
um I can also take questions at the end
um the final thing I thought you might
want to hear about is our upcoming
legislative initiatives
um so we have two that were
um
uh working on this year the first is has
to do with the money transmitters model
law and exemptions from licensure so
um money transmitters are for the most
part large entities that are licensed in
all 50 states
so it's important that um we make that
licensing process as business friendly
as possible so so that um entities it's
not a cumbersome process for them to get
licensed in different states
so in furtherance of that goal the
conference of State Bank supervisors
which is a trade organization that the
banking Department belongs to put forth
a money transmitter model law to the
states to encourage that um sort of ease
of licensure to make our laws match up
as as best you can taking into account
different states nuances
um so that was kind of a new initiative
from the csbs that we've been wrap
getting our arms around and we decided
this year that it would take a lot of
resources to try to fully um make that
work for New Hampshire so
um we focused on a section of that
monologue which is the exemptions from
licensure because one
um thing we've heard from licensed
entities is that there were certain
exemptions in other states laws that we
didn't have in our law and when we
reviewed those they made a lot of sense
to us
um so we thought that since we had
received a lot of phone calls about that
a lot of inquiries it would make sense
to take that portion of the model law as
a first step in trying to move it into
our law for money transmitters
so that's the first legislative
initiative we're working on the second
one is more of a technical fix so
um the banking Department sets by
Statute sets the interest rate for
escrow accounts associated with
mortgages so if you have an escrow for
your taxes to pay your taxes or
homeowners insurance we the interest
rate for that escrow account is set by
Statute
so a couple years ago we had a bill that
changed how we calculated that interest
rate so it used to be before that bill
um we would have all the state chartered
Banks submit their savings account rates
to us
and we would tally them up and average
them and subtract one and that would be
the interest rate for
um escrow accounts and as you might
imagine that was kind of a cumbersome
process it involved the entities
reporting to us we had to do some math
that's not so bad
um but you can imagine that it was a bit
cumbersome so and for years and years
and years it was always zero so a couple
years ago we changed that law working in
conjunction with the bankers to um tie
that interest rate amount to the federal
funds rate
so when we did that however we
inadvertently missed that it that same
exact language was in the consumer
credit uh mortgage Banker broker law so
then we realized it and we had a problem
because we still had to sort of
calculate that rate for all the mortgage
companies
so um this year we've sought to make
those match we're also working with the
bankers Association to work out
um some Kinks that they've uncovered in
the course of the last couple years
trying to work through that that change
um so that's the other major legislative
initiative that we're working on this
year
um and then obviously we will be
tracking any other bills that might
apply to us
um
so I think that's all I have prepared
I'm happy to answer any questions or um
talk about anything else anyone is
interested in
representative could you explain a
little bit about uh exemptions from
licensure for money transmitters
sure
um so um again money transmitters think
Western Union is a kind of more
traditional model of one also PayPal is
a my transmitter it's basically anybody
who say I took five dollars from you and
gave it to representative hunt I would
be a money transmitter if I engaged in
that business regularly
so um there's a series under our line I
hope you don't make me reel them off I'm
not prepared to reel off all the
exemptions but there are several
exemptions to licensure under current
law
um one example of one that we didn't
have in our law that it's in the model
law is an exemption for if um say it's
gonna com money transmitters are one of
our more complicated business models to
explain so I'm going to probably
oversimplify it
um
and hope that my money transmitter
expert who's listening at the office
doesn't yell at me
um so uh picture you have a bank account
and your bank contracts with a
third-party money transmitter to say you
want to send me money through your bank
account
just like venmo
they are like venmo but venmo would not
be one that I'm talking about Citizens
Bank uh my bank has one called Zell I
haven't used it but it's the other one
yeah Zell could be an example I'm not
sure that they
are technically a third party I would
have to it's very contract driven how
they contract with the bank but for
example purposes think of that
um we in our law currently don't have an
exemption so that third party has to be
um licensed by us
however in most instances the bank is
the one that holds the liability I don't
I can't speak exactly to Zell so please
put that aside for this purpose but they
have a contract that governs say they
mess up that transfer the bank is the
one who's responsible at the end of the
day not the money transmitter in that
instance we feel there's enough
protection for the consumer because the
bank will be standing behind that
transaction that the third party
wouldn't need a license in that scenario
so that's an example of one of the
examples so it isn't that there would be
no regulations that some other entity is
already regulated so you don't need
additional regulations correct thank you
I mean some of them are also kind of as
as somebody who's not like I have
subject matter experts in my
transmission some of them struck me I
was like oh is this an issue but one of
them is the U.S Postal Service
apparently some states have tried to
bring enforcement actions against the
U.S Postal Service for transmitting
money
um we've never done that it never seemed
like something to do but that is on the
list in the proposed spell
so things like that does that answer
your question thank you
um last last session we passed a
cryptocurrency
pieces of legislation and I'm curious as
to whether or not you have
uh had any
noticed anything in regards to that
legislation in terms of banking or that
you have to deal with or may may impact
your business
so um I believe what you're referring to
is the UCC governing um commercial
transactions in cryptocurrency I'm I'm
probably misstating it technically but
that was I believe the bill you're
referring to yeah
um so that bill
um really governs commercial
transactions between entities that don't
and those transactions don't necessarily
fall direct like we don't enforce the
UCC the UCC govern strength
contractual
excuse me transactions between entities
so that's not something I would expect
to see a lot of occasionally when we
examine an institution we might
um
see some interaction with the Uniform
Commercial Code but it's very minimal so
that I wouldn't expect to see anything
and I haven't
um so in terms of that though I have not
however we have been acutely aware of
cryptocurrency this fall we did
participate in the governor's
cryptocurrency
um commission study commission and
additionally
um several of the entities that you
perhaps heard about in the news did have
money transmitter licenses that governed
a small portion of their business
we have a specific law in New Hampshire
that states that money transmission
there companies that are money
transmitters for cryptocurrency to
cryptocurrency so say you have
cryptocurrency and you want to give it
to a person over here
The Entity that you give it to if you
just give the cryptocurrency that's not
subject to our laws our laws we only
license money transmitters who take in
cryptocurrency and give out fiat
currency
so we really had just a small sector of
entities that
sort of fell into that bubble of
cryptocurrency and that was from the
first a couple years ago where we did
the money transmitter we rewrote the
legislative the statute and then this
issue came up and then we made it clear
that it is not regulated by the banking
department and I believe that you do
have something on your web page that
informs consumers one should State what
that what that statement is yes I will
double check we just redid our website
it used to be pretty front and center
but I think it might have moved to the
consumer credit section but it makes it
clear that it that they do not regulate
the crypto transactions
representative purcelli
thank you for being here my question did
have to do with crypto but I'll broaden
it out the products are getting so
complicated the digital assets digital
products for our consumers so what are
some of the issues that you see that
would be impacting our consumers that
you're concerned about and where the
lines are being blurred between Banking
and securities what are you on the
lookout to protect consumers that we
might want to keep on our radar
um
so I would I think consumer education is
always important a lot of this requires
very clear sedatements because you might
as might notice I slowed down when I
talk about the cryptocurrency I want to
be really clear about what we regulate
and what we don't because that really
governs the sort of relief that a
consumer can potentially have because if
it falls under our jurisdiction it's
exempt from the consumer protection act
and we would we would handle any sort of
enforcement action associated with it
um
so I think it's important to educate
consumers and be really clear about what
is under our jurisdiction what isn't
that would be something that is
constantly on my mind
and are there any particular concerns
that you have that we would need to take
a look at as far as some of the newer
products
can't think of any off the top of my
head we we're pretty aggressive about
coming right forward when we find out
about new products and and dealing with
them and figuring we have a process of
the banking department where we can
accept
um requests from entities who might have
a question if they fall under our
jurisdiction and require a license or
not where they can request a no action
letter from us that details whether or
not they need a license so we try to
stay on top of it as best we can through
monitoring those and consumer complaints
and try to really get out ahead of it
mm-hmm
representative Burroughs thank you Mr
chair uh two quick questions one um
Keith could probably I'm sorry
representative Ammon could probably
answer this too has the governor's
Commission on crypto come out with a
report at this time or is it forthcoming
I believe it was submitted to the
governor
um I'm not sure if it's been uploaded to
the website yet
I haven't checked their website I
apologize yeah yeah it's been delivered
to the governor he's still reading it
okay but it hasn't been made public so
it should be any day or week you know I
would think very soon it was a week or
so a couple weeks ago now time flies
we're very busy it's pretty
comprehensive reports about 50 pages so
um follow up and just quick question do
you have on your website a list of the
personnel and how we contact them about
different issues yeah I believe so okay
yep it's kind of divided up
I apologize we did just get a new
website actually Ian's the person who um
is our web person
um but I believe it's divided up by
division so if you go to that it should
take you to a contact perfect thank you
representative Terry
thank you thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you commissioner galdieri for your
overview of the uh State banking
department and your work and the
response to questions thus far a couple
questions members of the committee will
be familiar with these because I asked
the same of the insurance department
folks what's the most difficult issue
that you're dealing with right now as a
department and number two I'm looking at
your uh I'm looking at your web page
here on my phone what there is a
consumer Complaint Form and instructions
do you have something comparable to what
the insurance department has and that is
a consumer guide to understand the
services that are provided by the state
banking department for their education
and their knowledge so two questions
please thank you so um we do have
several brochures that Ian is very
diligently updating
um they had gotten a bit out of date but
we're working on updating them and
making sure they're available in a
digital format we do have a guide on
there for how to fill out a Consumer
complaint and we have people who are
available at all times to answer the
phone and answer any questions people
may have so
it's like that that was that was the
second question okay good
yeah the most difficult issue with which
the department is dealing at this time
okay so I'd say you know a couple of
things about that
um we are as I'm sure everyone talks
about who will come before you you know
keeping
um obtaining retaining knowledgeable and
experienced staff is always something
that's on the Forefront I feel very
lucky at the banking Department we have
um compared to some agencies I shouldn't
even say this out loud but we have a
pretty good retention rate of Staff we
have several long-term staff some who
have been working for over 30 years at
the banking department so I feel really
lucky in that regard but it is something
that I constantly work at to maintain I
feel like one of my primary jobs as
commissioner is keeping and retaining
those staff because I can't do it all I
need experts who know what they're doing
to help me every day so that's always in
the Forefront of my mind I I feel lucky
that it's not a big problem but it's not
a big problem because we're constantly
working at it
um and then in terms of like more of a
subject matter kind of thing
um we have been dealing with a lot of
cryptocurrency uh inquiries we obviously
staffed the commission uh and are
constantly
um responding to inquiries about it
um all trying to get our arms around new
new products that might be related to
cryptocurrency it I don't know if that's
necessarily a problem but it's just a
part of our job that we are constantly
faced with and trying to get our arms
around
uh just say representative Cole I'm
looking that way thank you Mr chair
I want to Circle back to the escrow
accounts
what is the distance between your
calculated percentage and the federal
rate you're using
you calculated a percentage for the
escrow accounts now you're using a
federal rate for it what's the
difference between the two are they
close to each other well so they used to
be so historically the rate was Zero
um we'd tally up all the savings account
rates it would come up to a very small
average and then the law required us to
subtract one point from it so it was
always zero
um then we tied it to the federal funds
rate which at the time was Zero however
as I'm sure everyone is aware
um the they've been increasing the
amount of the federal funds rate pretty
steadily to try to combat inflation
um so that has brought the amount up
um but
similarly potentially I think we're all
aware that um
correspondingly you consumers have
access to
um places to park their money that have
a higher return on their you know rate
of return than historically when it was
all zero so it's sort of all they're all
sort of coming up together
um for what it's worth
representative is this another crypto
question yes it is it's very brief
um there's a lot of Finance transactions
Financial transactions that are
occurring here in the state and
around the world with cryptocurrencies
part of this our charge here is to
um have consumer protection Consumer
Affairs
so it bothers me that uh we don't who is
if somebody calls me with a problem
uh who am I going to refer them to
uh to to answer questions in regards to
whatever
uh you know thank God FTX wasn't you
know out of Nashua and New Hampshire but
uh there's a lot of transactional
uh financial banking like activity going
on and I'm I'm very uncomfortable but
with the lack of
any apparent desire to
regulate or have a place where somebody
can go and and make a complaint so you
can always come to us FTX was licensed
by us as a money transmitter for the
activities they did taking in
cryptocurrency and giving out fiat
currency so they did have a license for
that small portion of their business
um we're always happy to answer
questions
um if if a consumer comes to us with a
question like that and we feel it
doesn't fall under our jurisdiction but
it may fall under the Department of
Justice or the Securities Bureau we have
excellent working relationships with
those agencies and um have sharing
agreements in place that we can share
those complaints freely and make sure
that consumers concerns are addressed
assuming it falls under the jurisdiction
of one of those entities
um so that's what I would say I would
always encourage people who have
questions to come to us we have fully
staffed phones and emails and any way
that you may need
um in terms of jurisdiction our
jurisdiction is set by the statute
um so you know that would be something
that could potentially be addressed if
you had concerns
representative Ammon
yeah I just wanted to make clear that uh
even though crypto to crypto or digital
asset to digital asset it's still
covered by consumer protection it is oh
yes
and so you could file and that's in
that's in statute So you you're you're
um
uh constituate could file a complaint
with the Consumer Protection Bureau in
that instance yep and that's the
committee did that that was our our very
strong position was that they were not
going to be able to use the banking
Department's exemption because they're
not regulated by the Banks and that yes
you have a private right of the
restitution
you you call either us or that and if
it's not us we'll send you to the doj if
it's not the doj we send you to
Securities we work very closely together
most likely it would probably fall
underwater categories
so we can help you out but at the end of
the day you're going to have is it's
under the consumer protection act
so thank you very much uh commissioner I
have to say that that
um even I can learn something new every
day I'd never heard of the conference of
State Bankers State Bank supervisors
yeah they're supervisors yeah there are
trade organizations I never I guess I
never knew you know usually when the
insurance department come they all you
know tell that this is Nic and that I
don't know have we ever done anything
that was really like when we did the
recodification where they were we using
them as a platform to work from I don't
think so no they
not that they don't do Bank
of our legislative work
um we work even think when I did the
trust law I don't even remember them and
they don't um dabbled in that either
they definitely are involved in that but
not as heavily like I think mostly the
legislative initiatives tend to be the
consumer Consumer Credit division or
legislative initiatives right
but learn something new every day
thank you very much thank you okay so we
do have some people from the banking
industry here
so we'll start off from the New
Hampshire Bankers Association
good morning thank you chairman hunt
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
ourselves today my name is Christy
Merrill I'm president of the New
Hampshire Bankers Association and with
me is Ryan Hale he is VP government
relations for New Hampshire Bankers as
well
um we are a Statewide non-profit trade
Association we have the way our
membership works is the banks are our
members we have 38 members right now so
we have as the commissioner said we have
17 New Hampshire chartered Banks seven
federally chartered and 14 banks that
are based out of state we also have
trust companies as members as well
um and the banking industry in New
Hampshire employs about 6 000 people
Statewide and I think you all probably
know that the banking the banking
industry plays a really big part of New
Hampshire's economy so it's important
that um you know they they try to be
good corporate citizens they have a lot
of employees and they try to make the
economy go by issuing loans to
individuals and families and companies
and that was most recently seen through
the really high volume of PPP loans
during the pandemic
and so because of that we're really
excited that we there have been four de
novo Banks which are just banks that are
newly started from the ground up and
have to raise their Capital we've had
four in 15 years in New Hampshire so we
think that bodes really well and speaks
well to New Hampshire's economy and so
we're excited to see that and as good
corporate citizens they they are very
much invested in the community they try
to support the communities through
charitable service and charitable
Financial giving last October we hosted
our second annual what's known as New
Hampshire banks give back and so we ask
our members to just take one of their
normal Community Service events and
schedule that in the month of October
and so just really quickly we're happy
to say that in just the month of October
of last year we had 29 Banks participate
we had 409 volunteer events 2008
volunteers almost 3 000 hours
volunteered and 538 946 dollars and
monetary donations and that was just in
one month so that just is a snapshot of
what they do on a regular basis
I did want to also share that at New
Hampshire Bankers we also run an
insurance trust that was created in 1950
and that supports our members and so
from time to time in addition to banking
issues we obviously work with the
banking Department very closely we will
sometimes comment on a insurance
legislation as it may impact our
insurance trust we have are self-insured
we have self-insured medical we have
dental vision
um
health and a life and disability as well
and then the other thing I just wanted
to point out is the banking industry is
no surprise it's very heavily regulated
so they are under what's known as the
Dual regulatory system so every Bank
chooses their state primary regulator or
they have a state regulator or they and
they have a federal primary regulator
unless they decide that they want to
have a national Charter and so we do
have a couple of banks located in New
Hampshire that have opted to have a
national Charter so they are heavily
examined and they take turns with their
examiners and they are usually visited
for a few months or several weeks at a
time every 18 months so I just wanted to
mention that and hand it over to you
Ryan excellent
well thank you Christy and uh uh
congratulations to you all on uh being
elected and uh participating in this uh
committee um as Chrissy mentioned we uh
we're in front of this committee quite a
bit since all the banking uh um any stat
any Bill related to banking lands here
um I Christy mentioned that uh how the
banking industry is regulated I do have
a handout that I'll provide the
committee that kind of gives an overview
of that and essentially what we try to
do is just maintain balance between the
federal regulations and state
regulations so the the scale's not
tipped in One Direction versus the other
um and just to give you an idea a little
background uh behind how we make
determinations on positions we have a
legislative committee that meets once a
month we take a look at every bill that
could potentially impact the industry we
review it we look at the consequences we
look at parity and make a determination
recommendation on positions that the
association should take
um
we're here as a resource for the
committee I'll also hand out my business
card if you had all if you at any point
have questions in regards to any of the
banking related uh issues that come
before you please feel free to reach out
to myself or Christy we're happy to be
here as a resource for you and uh that's
all we have for you today happy to take
any questions the committee may have
representative Herbert
um thanks but uh I have a question that
you are a banking organization that is
regulated federally
and by the state
and I'm curious as to whether or not you
have been doing much business that's
cryptocurrency related
and uh and whether or not
I've read it from the federal side the
Congressional side some concerns about
that and I'm just wondering if if I
would like to see any information you
might have as to your interactions with
crypto and uh under whose regulation you
might fall under whether it's federal or
state in regards to that activity
foreign
okay thank you representative Herbert um
so we are a Statewide trade Association
a non-profit um but we do monitor
cryptocurrency very closely obviously
it's heavily debated in Washington
um where we stand right now the federal
Regulators have all basically said you
know before a bank engages in
cryptocurrency please talk to us first
if you're thinking about getting into
the space if you want a custody please
talk to your Regulators first so that
goes for the FDIC the Federal Reserve
and the OCC so that sort of have been
their position in terms of what our
members are hearing about crypto we have
heard some things come up
um on the fraud side of things so
customers who may have money in a
certain type of crypto wallet and then
something happens with that wallet and
they want the bank to hold them harmless
even though the bank really has no
purview over the customer's decision to
for the customer to put their money into
a cryptocurrency wallet they want the
bank to to hold them harmless and so
there have been some some questions
around fraud about that but we really
have not seen a lot of activity buyer
banks in the crypto space I think
they're trying to learn more about it
what is a regulatory framework and I
think ultimately the banks want to be
able to support their customers and what
it is they want so we can you know a lot
of customers trust their Banks and they
may want Banks to
custody crypto or to offer crypto so I
think they want to better understand it
and be open to the possibility of
someday getting in that space and you
know in a way that's compliant with
everything so I did want to also mention
that we had a representative on the
governor's cryptocurrency commission as
well so we worked with representative
Amman and that group through our our
representative on that as well
I would I would like for you to pay
close attention and uh it disturbs me a
little that uh
this committee really didn't get any
information to amount to much in the
last session there is a uh there is a
report that's coming forward and I'm
looking forward to seeing that
information but my main concern is
the citizens I represent don't end up
being on the hook for something that was
not foreseen uh and uh
we passed the legislation so it's in
part our responsibility I think to make
sure it's good legislation or not
we definitely do keep a close eye on
that and through the the governor's
commission that was certainly one of the
things that our banking the banking
representative talked about was consumer
protection so we agree I think that's
really important and
um you know you've seen some Regulators
come out and say that they're concerned
for example the fdaic is that some of
these groups are are suggesting that uh
crypto certain crypto firms are FDIC
insured when they're not and so I think
you know customers have to have their
eyes open and understand that certain
products do have FDIC insurance and
others don't there are Savvy investors
and that's the way they want to invest
their money and they should be able to
do that
um but that consumer protection is top
of mind for Bankers thanks
thank you very much thank you and just
to reiterate um if you all have any
questions from constituents about any
banking issues please don't hesitate to
reach out okay great
yes representative
thank you guys
so are you guys doing credit unions
who's doing the credit unions now
I know right
uh okay because I thought
all right so I I've somehow placed
myself in the worst position of any
lobbyists and that's between legislators
and lunch so uh real briefly uh my name
is Tom prasall I'm with uh Demers and
praisal we are lobbying firm here in
Concord comprised mainly of James Demers
myself Sean Thomas and Jonathan Melanson
we have about 40 clients in this
industry space we have the Mortgage
Bankers and Brokers Association of New
Hampshire which is a Statewide trade
Association comprised of Mortgage
Banking professionals we work
collaboratively with the banking
Department the bankers Association the
credit unions and others on a variety of
issues we also represent Bank of America
and One Financial
in addition if I can take just 10
seconds and tell you we have a again 40
clients many of which come before this
committee so we also represent the
retail association Walmart FedEx
um we represent centene corporation
which you just heard from their previous
Insurance uh department is one of the
state's Managed Care organizations as
well as Pharma and several
pharmaceutical individual pharmaceutical
companies so uh one of us will typically
before be before this committee on a
regular basis and as you know everyone
who's spoken before me has said please
use us as a resource if you have any
questions we're here to help and if we
don't know the answer we will get it for
you as soon as we can so with that I'll
let you know Tom why don't you just care
about the other names within the MERS
James Demers myself Tom krasel um Sean
Thomas and Jonathan Melanson are the
primary folks in our firm and they are a
tag team so you never know who you're
going to get in any given day yep so but
we'll find out the answer to any
question you may have within reason
thank you Tom thank you okay so uh the
medical society we see the hospital
Association I'm sorry
good morning everyone
um just um wanted to introduce myself on
Paula menahan I'm the senior vice
president of state government relations
for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
um so I am here often
um with any health insurance bills so I
will see you often
um and then I have some colleagues also
that are also registered lobbyists but
primarily you will see me but Brooke
Belanger is a new team member so she is
following a lot of insurance issues at
the association and works very closely
with our revenue cycle folks so CFOs and
patient financial services and deals
with a lot of insurance issues as well
as Kathy Bizarro thundberg who's our
executive VP and then Steve onnan
sometimes is here and he's our president
so but you can certainly contact me if
you have any questions and I do have
information it's just at the printer
relative to our hospitals we represent
all 33 house hospitals in the state
including our five specialty hospitals
and 26 acute care hospitals so I have
some information that I will get to you
as soon as it comes back from the
printer but we represent all the
hospitals in the state so happy to be a
resource as well so thank you email that
to everybody I will I will
yeah and we do have a question just a
quick question sure are the all the
people online that we need to contact
for different questions yes um primarily
just start with me though and then I
will um but yes
um they're we're all online but I will
email you yeah you're the primary I am
the primary yeah yeah so nice to meet
everyone
you know you give that hospitals
represent such a huge portion of our
economy you would absolutely think
commerces
we'll see Paula plenty
so
uh
you have a question uh well more of a
request uh uh first of all thank you for
asking um the various organizations to
email their information to us
um I'm trying to store everything
electronically as much as I can I am the
same way so if um if everybody who
testifies before us uh could email us
their handouts
um I think this would be very helpful
and their contact information that's the
key thing and the context you want their
cell phone numbers thank you
okay I heard so auto dealers
don't really have anything in here
except maybe consumer protection we
sometimes this is auto dealers is uh the
one little in the consumer protection
act in our famous little uh uh
exemptions is that that we have one line
in there that is just for auto dealers
and it is because they become Bankers
for a brief shiny moment when they take
your banking application for your loan
yes Mr chairman when we arrange
financing
uh thank you for the opportunity I'll
take the title from Tom of being the
last lobbyist between you and lunch so
I'll um I'll be brief I'm Dan Bennett
I'm with the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association we're a trade group for the
motor vehicle industry in New Hampshire
about 500 businesses 14 000 employees uh
every corner in every community of the
state we are the big Garage Mahal
franchise dealerships and where the
little independent inspection station
and string of light parking lot folks so
um we cover the whole industry uh
franchise and independent
um we are regulated by the insurance
department who you heard before
primarily because a lot of our members
are Collision repairs so you may hear
from us on collision repair issues
Insurance related issues uh it's really
a a three-legged stool between the
consumer the repairer and the carrier in
the uh Collision Repair world and then
with the banking Department we were
licensed primarily as retail sellers in
a few instances where sales finance
companies which are the buy here pay
here which is when the dealer also acts
as the bank but primarily it's as retail
sellers so we work very closely
with the banking Department
[Music]
um
sometimes too close over the last few
months one thing I would like to bring
up and and highlight really highlight is
as approaching first of the year we had
a real licensing scare for a number of
retail sellers who potentially had uh
licenses that were going to expire due
to no fault of their own uh primarily
because of a federal IRS related issue
Amelia and her team were so pro-business
so pro-consumer in being solution
oriented that we reached the first of
the year deadline
there were a few instances where an
arrangement was made so that these folks
could continue to operate without losing
their license some of her staff and I
were on the phone at times three to four
times a day personally touching
businesses uh all over the state the
resolution wound up being entirely
satisfactory and again I just want to
let you know how not just pro-business
but also pro-consumer her Department
um was rolling into first of the year so
a real kudos to them
um one of the other programs that I want
to highlight too and at some point I
will drop off for all of you in addition
to electronically sending out contact
information is a reference to our
autocap program and our autocap program
is one that resolves conflicts between
our members and citizens who may have
um difficulty or conflict related to
vehicle sales or service a lot of times
it's really just miscommunication I
didn't know what tires for life really
meant or the owner didn't know what one
of the salesmen may have said and it may
have been an error so through
communication and connection we can
resolve most issues and it's the reason
the Attorney General's office refers
most uh vehicle-related complaints to us
to our auto program our autocap program
first so the reason that I'm going to
give the information for you is that if
you have a constituation issue if
someone comes to you refer them to us we
can help we can help make that
connection uh establish and enable that
communication so you will see uh you
will see us often in this committee uh
potentially hear from us as well we do
also engage and work with the firm of
Dennehy and boulay so you may hear from
them as well periodically throughout the
session but other than that I just want
to introduce myself thank you for the
opportunity I look forward to working
with you if there's any information at
all that we can provide related to the
motor vehicle industry business please
let us know if we can connect you to one
of the local businesses you know in your
in your neighborhood in your backyard
those really are the true experts right
those are the folks that are living and
breathing it and doing it every day so
we can gladly make those connections
um so with that thanks and I'll take any
questions if any
we do have a question
Mr chair thank you for being here
um the um collision repair shops there I
live in Manchester there are many repair
shops and there are many repair shops in
neighborhoods and I'm not sure
um how to get information about the air
quality in the neighborhood I guess it
might be EPA but it just seems like many
of these collisions small that have been
around for a long time really should not
be operating in these areas because of
the you know systems they have in place
to clean the air or you know make sure
that the surrounding neighborhood is not
inundated with
you know air quality that's not
sufficient yes so I think I can answer
that question for you in two ways one
important thing about the collision
repair industry and the emerging
technology is that most paint a lot of
most of the paint that's being used for
vehicles these days is actually
waterborne so those haps called
hazardous air pollutants that you're
concerned about are actually not no
longer in the paints anymore so the the
painting process has actually gotten
much more environmentally friendly so
those potential sources are removed the
second part to answer that question is
the jurisdiction for those operations is
strictly under the Department of
Environmental Services New Hampshire and
their air Resources Division they have
folks that are dedicated uh through the
sbtap Small Business technical
assistance program another the acronym
of alphabet soups who regulate those
businesses that would be able to help
you with that with those concerns yeah
just another question about
um the the new paints that they're using
how can um did they have to uh do they
have to use these new paints or or how
are they regulated is that EPA or uh
Department of environment so the the de
yes so the Des doesn't require
waterborne paints however most folks are
moving towards them
um it's a it's as mentioned it's an
emerging technology it's a different
drying technique as well it requires
less heat so it's less energy intensive
so it's actually a less costly way to
paint a vehicle
um so it's dried actually with airflow
instead of heat it's not baked any
longer but all those paints and those
processes are regulated by Des
okay thanks well as long as they don't
have pfases in them then it'll be okay
that's paint not bumper and upholstery
it's a different section
okay great thank you very much thank you
Henry
I was gonna wait for liquor for you
Henry but you know I
but you do other things like dogs at the
restaurants and
um so my name is Henry beyou and uh I'm
with she Infinity Capital group we are a
lobbying firm that represents a variety
of clients there are two that get me
before this committee uh more often than
not and the first is the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association so
all the liquor laws come here
Food Service issues come here uh dogs in
restaurants come here that's been a
popular one over the past several years
we've solved that one now yeah but it's
a fun industry uh to represent and to
work with most of the restaurants in New
Hampshire are independently owned so
they're your neighbors and you have a
lot of they're they're they're all in
your districts so they're fun to
represent and then I also have the um
American Council of Life insurers their
trade Association that provides life
insurance disability insurance
retirement plans long-term care dental
vision different kinds of products like
that they have a bill that they are uh
that they have filed for this session
and starting in the Senate side it's uh
what I would consider housekeeping you
can be the judges of that hopefully it
gets here and we get it to the
governor's desk but so I'll be here uh
with them on that but
that's it
he's been around a long time so we were
talking uh we both started at the same
time in 1986 we've both been here 36
years is coming up my 37th year and so
yeah
anybody else
would like to Mr boulay you want to say
anything
that's true okay it's all set yeah
whatever he said okay great thank you
all very much and uh we'll break for
lunch and we'll see you all back at 1
15.
foreign
hey Dan
yeah we can do it that way and the other
thing is it's on YouTube
you know run it through like dictation
software on YouTube I did that as a
backup
so I try to get as much as I could here
the trick was when question and answer
right you got to type in who's saying
what
so you have to be good at the
there's like shortcuts on the keyboard
that's that was the one thing I was like
at least make a note so you could go
back and say oh this this is
representative so on so asking that
question but it's gonna be a lot of
handwritten for me too okay yeah yeah
okay I mean
but
yeah I got good at that like the second
end of the second year I got pretty good
at it yeah so
it's not Michael
all right why don't we get started
better late than never uh attorney
Garrett
I didn't didn't see you behind that
speaker he was like where is he
where is he
okay so uh the Attorney General's office
we have two divisions that that uh have
we have interests in
and how long have you now you've been
doing consumer protection this three
years now
four years yeah okay cool
great so all I ask is uh holy Mike you
know hit the button and pull it close
right
the red is on yes there we go to
everything else yeah great right so
think of it as when you're in front of
the Supreme Court
it's hot hot mic
hear me okay yep
ready yes
morning every or afternoon everybody my
name is Brandon garad I'm the chief of
the consumer protection and antitrust
Bureau at the New Hampshire Department
of Justice so I'm going to do two things
well I'll do three things for you this
afternoon let me give you an overview of
the consumer protection and antitrust
Bureau both the makeup of the bureau and
the various uh areas of law that we
enforce I'm going to highlight for you a
couple of things that you will be
hearing from me and my staff throughout
the year in the in the various bills
that come up under Consumer Protection
Law that'll give an opportunity for
anybody to ask any questions that you
might have at the end
so the Consumer Protection Bureau of the
Attorney General's office consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau of the
Attorney General's office I believe is
the second largest Bureau in the office
behind the criminal Bureau and we handle
an incredibly diverse body of things
at the heart of what we do though is New
Hampshire's consumer protection act
which is RSA 358 a it makes it unlawful
for anyone in the course of Commerce to
engage in unfair or deceptive Acts or
practices
the statute gives a number of examples
of things that are by definition unfair
and deceptive Acts or practices things
like representing that a product has
specific endorsements when it actually
doesn't have those endorsements
um things like making a representation
that a product you know will produce a
certain result when in fact that's not
true it also includes an extremely broad
catch-all which is anything that meets
the legal definition of unfair or
deceptive Acts or practices that's
committed in the course of Commerce
Falls within our statute so there's two
big parts to that the first is it has to
be in the course of Commerce so we do
not have any authority over private
transactions one sale between one person
to another uh somebody you know sells
their car on Facebook Marketplace we
have no Authority
um to regulate that sale at all
um that's something that you know if
somebody made a misrepresentation in the
course of that sale that would have to
be handled through the private civil
courts however if it's in Commerce if
it's a car dealership or you know
somebody who has you know regularly
contributed to Commerce in the state by
making it their business to sell cars
that would fall within the purview of
the consumer protection act so then you
have so if it's in the course of
Commerce the next question is is the
practice unfair or deceptive and if it
doesn't meet the you know number of
identified things in the statute or the
surrounding statutes that are identified
as unfair deceptive Acts or practices we
have a body of case law that we apply to
a scenario to determine whether it rises
to the level of something that the
Attorney General's office in the state
of New Hampshire has an interest in
investigating and Prosecuting or whether
it's something that's more appropriate
appropriately resolved in civil courts
between private parties and I'll spare
you the details of you know the legalese
that the courts have used to interpret
what amounts to an unfair deceptive act
or practice what it basically boils down
to is there has to be a sufficient level
of intentional wrongdoing or intentional
deceptiveness by the perpetrator so a
simple mistake
um would not be a unfair deceptive act
or practice a breach of contract you
know somebody contracts for somebody to
build them a house they start building
it then something you know out of the
blue comes up contractor walks off the
job that's a breach of contract that
would be resolved in civil courts but if
you have that same case where the
contractor makes certain representations
to the the customer says if you give me
you know this much money up front I'll
take it and I'll purchase all your
materials I'll get you a great deal then
they abscond you never see them again
and we can prove that you know there was
a certain level of intentional
wrongdoing by that contractor at the
point where the commerce was commenced
that's the type of analysis that we do
on all the complaints we receive to
determine whether or not something is
within the jurisdiction of the Consumer
Protection Bureau to investigate and
possibly prosecute under the consumer
protection act
so the way we review cases and receive
cases primarily is through our consumer
protection
complaint submission process you go
through our website there's a forum
where folks can print or submit an
electronic form specifically articulate
what they believe a business did that
was unfair and deceptive we have a
volunteer hotline where people can call
in and they get some guidance on how to
do that process but what it results do
is thousands of complaints each year
about businesses in the state that have
allegedly engaged in unfair deceptive
Acts or practices so our process you
know very very generally I review every
single one of those complaints in
conjunction with various paralegals in
the bureau if we believe that based on
what the consumer is alleging to us this
Rises to the level of assuming it's true
an unfair deceptive act or practice we
typically send those complaints to the
business ask them to respond provide
their side of the story in writing
businesses often do businesses will
often
make the situation right at that point
oftentimes a simple letter from the
Attorney General's office that tells
people you know hey it's the Consumer
Protection Bureau we received this
complaint about unfair and deceptive
Acts or practices and we're watching you
know give us your side of the story that
results in an enormous amount of
consumer restitution each year
which is terrific when it works out that
way unfortunately there's a number of
times when it doesn't work out that way
we either get no response from the
business or we'll get a less than
satisfactory response from the business
we have certain tools under the consumer
protection act that we then use to
enforce our statute we have a subpoena
power where we can compel Witnesses we
can compel documents we can even compel
the business themselves to come to the
Attorney General's office place them
under oath ask them a series of
questions in order to investigate
whether the consumer's claims are
accurate and decide whether or not we
can prove that the act or practice that
the consumers alleging actually Rises to
that level of unfair deceptive
if it is we have a number of enforcement
Options under our statute we have a
criminal enforcement statute for the
most severe unfair and deceptive Acts or
practices it's a misdemeanor if we bring
it against an individual it is a felony
if we bring it against a business the
difference between bringing a crime
against a business versus an individual
if it's an individual they're subject to
jail time if it's a business they are
subject to a fine of up to a hundred
thousand dollars
if the so you know we we bring criminal
actions routinely but we tend to reserve
them for the most serious offenses it's
a less serious offense we feel that we
can prove it or the evidence doesn't
quite rise to the level of a criminal
offense we also have the power to file a
lawsuit on behalf of the State of New
Hampshire against the business we have
the power to ask the court to do a
number of things the first is to order
any injunctive relief that is necessary
to ensure that the unfair deceptive
actual practice stops usually it's a
court order that orders the practice to
stop sometimes it can be a court order
putting the business out of business or
you know limiting their business so that
sufficient consumer protections are in
place to make sure that consumers in the
future are protected a great example of
this is if you have a contractor who's
taking deposits from people a court can
order that they're no longer allowed to
take deposits so they might be able to
continue working but you're able to
alleviate the risk to Future consumers
through a court order that says you know
for a certain period of time you're no
longer allowed to take payments in
advance things like that
so we get injunctive relief we also have
the ability to get a civil penalty of up
to ten thousand dollars per violation we
have the ability to get restitution for
victims and we also have the ability to
recover our own
attorney's fees and investigative costs
that are associated with conducting the
investigation
and
um the third option that we have this is
for you know first-time offenders or you
know cases where we look at something
and we see you know it's a it's a
serious offense but it's on the very
very minor end of the spectrum from like
you know this person needs to be in jail
to oh this person just made a mistake
and you know it is sorry and is willing
to work it out and take responsibility
we can file what's called an assurance
of discontinuance it's basically a
promise that's enforceable and filed
with the court between the business and
us and we can put whatever terms we want
into that Assurance of discontinuance
can account for restitution can it
account for financial penalties and can
also bake in injunctive terms into that
uh the difference is the the business
doesn't actually get sued doesn't have a
lawsuit filed against them doesn't have
a judgment against them so this was a
big incentive for them to resolve things
through a Assurance of discontinuance
that way that is how we investigate and
prosecute the majority of our consumer
protection cases
uh the consumer protection act is
designed so that the enforcement for it
is shared it's not all the Attorney
General's office uh private citizens
also have the ability specifically to
file a private right of action under 358
a almost anything that we could bring in
action for they could bring in action
for it the remedies are just different
they can't get you know civil penalties
they can't bring Criminal action but
they can get injunctive terms and they
can also get damages depending on the
level of the mental state that they can
prove they can also get double or
sometimes triple damages which is
something that we don't have the ability
to get so there's actually an incentive
for consumers to bring these cases on
their own and share that burden of
enforcement with the Attorney General's
office because as I'll talk about in a
minute we have limited resources in our
Bureau where it forces us to only take
the most serious cases but we do try to
do as much as possible
that's our Consumer Protection work the
bureau also does a number of other
things so it's consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau so I'll talk a little
bit about our antitrust enforcement
there's a separate Statute in New
Hampshire 356
which is our antitrust statute it makes
it unlawful for businesses uh businesses
that have Monopoly power to abuse that
Monopoly power in a way that limits
competition or two businesses to decide
to come together uh to merge or for one
business to acquire another business in
a way that significantly harms
competition in the state of New
Hampshire so if we have complaints about
a business that has a potential Monopoly
power that is you know abusing it in a
way that harms consumers we can
investigate that if you have two
businesses that are merging or one
businesses buying another
our antitrust Bureau is very busy in
reviewing those proposed transactions to
determine whether on the other side of
that and you have one corporate entity
whether that will be harmful for
consumers because now there's less
choice in the market there's less
competition and there's less incentive
to keep prices low
that statute similar to the consumer
protection act statute has both civil
and criminal penalties we tend to use
the Civil remedies much more I I don't
believe we've used the criminal remedies
in quite some time but the possibility
is always there
the bureau has a separate elder abuse
and financial exploitation unit this is
one lawyer one victim witness Advocate
and a Elder coordinator specialist and
they are tasked with overseeing
investigating and Prosecuting the most
serious cases of Elder Financial abuse
and neglect in the state of New
Hampshire they also work with the police
department's county attorney's offices
Adult Protective Services to make sure
that if there are cases out there of
adults be Elder adults being scammed
abused neglected or even you know
harming themselves that we're providing
education and a resource to make sure
that those cases are all dealt with
appropriately and that those
perpetrators are brought to justice so
the Attorney General's Bureau is a
purely criminal Bureau they take the
most serious cases in the state of Elder
Financial exploitation as well as
criminal neglect
the bureau is also tasked with the
registration of health clubs and martial
arts studios on an annual basis there
are various consumer protection laws in
the state where if you are running a
health club or a martial arts studio
you're required to file an annual
registration with our Bureau to prove
that you're complying with all those
laws the most important and this is the
reason that health clubs in martial arts
studios are regulated At All by the
Attorney General's office is that it's a
business that lends itself to signing
people up in advance for services that
they're going to receive in the future a
lot of health clubs martial arts studios
their business model is to sell at a
reduced price the ability to sign up for
their services for a whole year or for
six months or for a long period of time
and you know the question is what
happens to those consumers if the
business doesn't exist you know for the
duration of that contract so there are
laws where the health clubs are required
to provide to us
um proof that they are complying with
various consumer protection laws most
importantly if they are accepting
um prepaid contracts selling services in
advance of when folks are going to
receive them if they're doing enough of
that they're required to obtain a surety
bond that bond is filed with our office
and if the club were to go out of
business and there were still contracts
that had to be honored the consumers
would be protected they'd be able to
draw on that Bond and they'd be able to
receive a refund
the bureau also oversees condominium
registrations and
subdivision initial
uh disclosure initial sales of land
subdivisions
um so our role in this is pretty much
limited to for both condos and
subdivisions the initial sale of a of a
condominium or subdivision units or lots
to the public they're similar to health
clubs there are a number of consumer
protection laws that we have to review
and approve that before the sale can
take place make sure the consumers are
getting full disclosure about what
they're going to receive if they buy
into a condominium or they buy into a
subdivision that the disclosures that
are being made to them about what's
actually going to be included you know
roads water things like that they
actually have the money to live up to
those promises
we review those we issue initial
registration once the Condominiums are
you know established and they elect a
board of directors and there's various
issues that arise between the owners and
the board we tend to not get involved in
those matters unless they are you know
serious enough that it rises to the
level of the Attorney General's office
being involved those matters are usually
left for resolution between unit owners
and the condominium boards we see them
as self-governing entities they that's
the purpose of them you could buy in
it's a democratic process you have a
vote you can elect a board and the board
speaks for the condo and so therefore
the the remedy that folks tend to have
is to vote out the board of directors if
they don't think they're doing a good
job
so that in a nutshell is the body of
work that the consumer protection
antitrust Bureau is responsible for
at least by Statute the reality is that
we also take on a number of serious
criminal matters
um that are referred to us by the
banking Department the Bureau of
Securities regulation who I think you're
going to hear from later and the
department of insurance we also do if a
case you know looks like an unfair and
deceptive act or practice like we said
if it's against an individual I'll keep
using contractors because it's our most
constant source of complaints an unfair
and deceptive Act of practice is only a
misdemeanor against a contractor if it's
an individual we also have General
criminal authority to prosecute those
cases as felonies if they meet the the
all the elements of those crimes so we
tend to bring a lot of serious
Securities fraud cases theft by
unauthorized taking cases step by
misapplication of property cases theft
by deception cases large criminal
prosecutions that include unfair and
deceptive Acts or practices but are
expanded to include other violations of
the RSA because the penalties are much
higher
so that's the work that the bureau does
there are in terms of bills that you're
going to see and what you can expect to
hear from me and my staff throughout
this session and you're going to hear
from one of them on Thursday for a bill
unfortunately I'm not available but one
of our lawyers is going to come talk to
you
there's really two issues where there
are bills and there are bills every year
where the consumer protection act is
expanded to include new conduct or there
are new areas where the legislature is
considering delegating a responsibility
to the consumer protection antitrust
Bureau for enforcement and the one that
you're going to hear most consistently
from me is resources
as you can see by you know what I've
given you today is just a nutshell we
have five lawyers that do Consumer
Protection work two lawyers that do
antitrust work and one lawyer that does
elder abuse work and each one of them is
about at capacity we try to take
everything that we can but each time
that the statute is expanded it merits a
consideration of resources because every
every time the bureau's work goes up
caseloads go up expectations go up and
we want to make sure that we can
continue to operate at the highest
possible level to hold these
perpetrators accountable but you know as
the statute gets expanded more and more
stuff is you know added to it we tend to
come over and have the conversation
about resources to give you an idea of
you know realistically is the thing that
you're proposing adding something that
we could
fulfilled with the resources we have or
whether it would be something that would
require more
so that's something that you can expect
to hear from us this year uh the second
thing is enforceability
so when
the con the consumer protection act is
amended or added to or there's any other
conduct in Commerce the the legislature
wants to make unlawful a priority for me
if I'm going to be the one enforcing it
is making sure that I'm communicating to
the legislature if I see any issues with
enforceability because it's important at
this juncture to make sure that the
language is such that on the other side
of it when it becomes law in the state
of New Hampshire that our Bureau is in a
position to actually do what you want us
to do be able to enforce this thing to
investigate these and to prosecute these
successfully and sometimes there are
inconsistencies or ambiguities in the
statute or there's a question of how we
would enforce it how we would be able to
investigate it we tend to be here to
testify and bring those issues to your
attention
uh that's generally all I came prepared
to talk to you all about today I look
forward I know I won't see you on
Thursday I'll see you a number of times
throughout this legislative session I
look forward to to speaking with all of
you and answering any questions you have
throughout the year and also right now
if anybody has any questions
representative Gibbs
sorry I missed your name my name is
Brandon garad g-a-r-o-d
thank you um your director of consumer
protection yes and I have a suggestion
to avoid interrupting actually I was
trying to look up the name of the
director of the consumer protection
online but
it's not your name is not on the edgy
website as far as I could find it
um I my suggestion would be to have the
name of the director consumer protection
just so everybody knows who's
responsible
I think that is a very fair suggestion I
will note that the Department of Justice
is currently going through a complete
overhaul of our website and I have been
tasked with rewriting the consumer
protection page so I think that's a very
good suggestion I will take it into
account yeah and so you're Brian gerott
j-a-r-o-t Brandon Brandon garage so you
you'll email all the committee members
you can you do house Commerce if you can
just email all of us with your contact
information sure that'd be great but in
general the department uh is always been
it's about the hotline the consumer
protection hotline so they have not so
much giving the calls directly to you
because
he he screens his calls because he
doesn't want to get any any fake phone
calls we've learned that in past
hearings so always happy to take phone
calls it's always good to know he's on
the other side exactly so uh so yeah
he's sending us that information should
be great representative Yemen
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
testifying of course uh I had a question
um
are there any instances where uh there
would be a class action taken let's say
there's a contractor who's doing the
same thing to multiple people around the
state and maybe some of those people
don't even know that it was done to them
is there any class action enforcement
so the consumer protection act includes
the ability for class action lawsuits
but I think it's important to note that
a true class action lawsuit is one is a
civil lawsuit brought on behalf of a
larger class it's a private civil remedy
the Attorney General's office doesn't
have the ability to bring a class action
lawsuit but what you're referring to a
situation where multiple consumers are
harmed by the same person that is
something that almost exclusively that's
what we look at when I say you know
we're we're looking at the most serious
cases it's the ones that are affecting
multiple people and we have the ability
to bring an unfair and deceptive actor
practices either a criminal case or a
civil case and to name multiple victims
in that it's not a traditional class
action so to speak but all the rights
and remedies that I talked about earlier
we can get that for multiple people in
one civil complaint or through multiple
Criminal prosecutions
yes representative
thank you
um
we had a few bills last year regarding
um condominium associations
uh and uh there it seems to be a trend I
know in Manchester for Manchester where
the managers of this of the condominium
associations or the you know the
property
um needs to be addressed before the
board is addressed so the Association
members are not able to speak to board
members they have to address their
problem their issues to with managers
and not the board are you involved with
any of those issues so part of the
Condominium Act and part of our
registration process they have to pass
bylaws we review the bylaws initially
but once the bylaws are put into effect
the bylaws control the process for the
individual condominium they have the
ability to decide what their own process
is and so we don't get involved in you
know help telling people how they should
write bylaws that's the responsibility
we look at it from the initial you know
the this is what's going to be disclosed
to Consumers this is what people are
buying into and if it complies with law
we register them if they want to change
bylaws later on then they have to vote
for it and approve it as part of a
democratic process of being in a
condominium so it all depends on the
individual condominium if that's the
process that they voted on and
anticipated in their bylaws then that's
what they have to comply with and if
it's not in their bylaws then
very extensive Condominium Act that lays
out you know various requirements a lot
of it defers to the bylaws we also have
published rules for Condominiums so a
combination of the the bylaws and the
rules it would but it would depend on
the specific situation yep okay thank
you
great thank you very much thank you all
that was very impressive I think you
covered it all I think so
okay so the other uh element of the
Attorney General's office is a
charitable trust division
and
attorney Garrett I so this is another
one that I picked up over over time
terrible trust uh statutes all the bills
used to all go to go to Judiciary and uh
um
not sure which which bill I was a as a
star on that but but uh he he has a
Terry Knowles who was running the
division for a very long time and uh she
um was made sure all those bills came to
here
so welcome to the Commerce Committee no
thank you very much Mr chairman um good
afternoon everyone my name is Michael
Haley I am the assistant director of
charitable trust the director
unfortunately was not able to make it
today
um I've been with the Attorney General's
office since August of 2020 and I've
been in the charitable trust unit since
August of this year so I'm relatively
new um bear with me have you met Terry
yet uh yes yeah we did not overlap but I
had mattered
um so I'm gonna follow a similar pattern
to attorney Gerard
um basically give you an overview of
what our unit does and then um what who
we're composed of and then give you an
opportunity to ask some questions
um so the regulation of charitable
trusts by the Office of the Attorney
General is a very old tradition in the
common law it goes back to 1601 under
the reign of Elizabeth the first so
we're to create a dedicated charitable
trust unit is the state of New Hampshire
so that happened in 1943 so we have big
shoes to fill and we take that
um that responsibility very seriously
um our mission is to protect the
Public's interest in the assets and
organizations that are dedicated to
charitable purposes in the state of New
Hampshire
um and so uh you probably have the first
question is what is a charity our
statute defines a charity to be any
entity that is a 501c3 under
um the federal IRS Internal Revenue code
or any organization that is soliciting
charitable donations from the general
public so even some entities that are
not 501 c3s if they are collecting
charitable donations from the general
public they fall under our jurisdiction
some instances where that happens so for
example
um like a fraternal organizations like
an Elks Club they are a membership
organization they are not organized for
charitable purposes but sometimes they
will solicit charitable donations from
the general public rather than just from
their members and when they do that they
fall under our jurisdiction
they're required to register with us and
to report to us if they do that
um so one of our main duties is to
establish a register of charitable
trusts all of the Charities that operate
in the state of New Hampshire whether
they are organized here or organized
elsewhere and simply are active here
have to register with our office
at the time when they register there's a
bunch of things they have to provide to
us such as their bylaws their 501c3
determination letter we review all those
things very carefully when they come in
to make sure that we set them off on the
right foot we recognize that Charities
do an incredible amount of very
important work in the state we're more
or less agnostic to the purpose that the
charity does we think that the Charities
um that it's important that they are
healthy and functional so when they
register with us we review their
documents really carefully to make sure
that they are going to be successful in
achieving their charitable mission
um most of the documents that they
provide to us are public knowledge
they're publicly available the register
including their their financial
documents
um that's all available to the public
because Charities are meant to serve the
public so that information should be
available there's some exemptions to
that such as the home addresses and
contact information of board members
those are not public information but in
general if you're curious about a
charity what they're spending their
money on things like that you can you
can get that information from us
um we also publish a directory of
Charities that's available on our web
page and it just is a full list of all
the Charities that are registered with
us and whether they are in good standing
with us if they are not in good standing
and then there's also a third
designation called suspended which
sounds bad but it actually just means
that they're a very small organization
that has applied to be to suspend their
reporting requirements with us for a
period of five years especially if
they're something if they're a five
thousand dollar a year organization it's
a little bit taxing for them to have to
submit annual reports all the time so
they can apply to suspend so if you look
at the list and you see suspended it
doesn't mean a bad thing you can still
feel confident feel comfortable donating
to that charity
um another big thing that we do is um
I'm sure you're aware most of the
healthcare providers in the state of New
Hampshire are non-profits there are a
few exceptions but all the big names are
our non-profit organizations and when
they
um engage in what's called an
acquisition transaction which is more
colloquial thought of as a merger or an
acquisition we review that transaction
and what we're reviewing for mostly is
we're making sure that when a a hospital
or another type of healthcare
organization agrees to be acquired by
some other entity that their board has
engaged in due diligence that they've
selected their acquirer carefully that
they are making sure that the
acquisition is in the best interest of
the community and of the organization we
want don't want these Healthcare
organizations to be bought up and
stripped for parts when they're playing
a very important role in keeping New
Hampshire Healthy so we review that we
make sure that but if there are
charitable assets that are being
exchanged that they're being exchanged
for fair value there are a number of
other factors that we'll go through and
we currently have three of those
transactions that we're looking at right
now
um Healthcare charitable trusts are also
required every five years at least to
put together a community needs
assessment often they will work with
other health care organizations in their
areas to come up with these and then
every year they're required to file a
community benefits plan which basically
tells the public how far along they are
in addressing those Community needs and
what their plan is to continue to
achieve those they can update their
their Community needs assessment more
often than five years but that's the the
minimum and then they provide us with
their updates every year we post all of
those on our website so you're welcome
to go and see how all these charitable
trusts or Healthcare charitable trusts
are doing in their addressing of
community needs there
um we also register professional
fundraisers and fundraising Council
many of you may have received a call at
home from someone saying I'm raising
money for veterans would you like to
give a donation
um we uh a lot of um of charitable
organizations engage with these these
call centers essentially who will
solicit donations on their behalf and
that's that's legal we can't stop them
from Contracting to do that we want to
make sure however that when people make
those donations they know what
percentage of Their donation is going to
the charity and what percentage is going
to the person who's making the call so
we um they're required to report that
information to us we make that publicly
available so if you receive one of those
calls we encourage people to look on our
website see what the arrangement is and
if you if you think that it's better
that you just give directly to the
charity that you you make that decision
for yourself
uh we also work on what's called
commercial co-ventures and charitable
sales promotions you may have seen uh
especially with the um the conflict in
the Ukraine recently you've gone to
maybe a restaurant and they say uh for
every beer you purchase one dollar will
go towards towards Ukraine
um the restaurant is not a charitable
nonprofit so typically they will they
will have to contract with a non-profit
and they are raising money on their
behalf we'll review that contract and
we'll make sure that that it meets the
standards that are laid out in the
statute
um let's see uh we don't have very much
involvement with the um with the
charitable gaming
um that's mostly handled by The Lottery
Commission however if uh and a charity
is required to register with us as in
they're not one of those fraternal
organizations that's not required then
they have to be in good standing with us
in order to qualify for charitable
gaming so that's our our interaction
with them we'll see uh typically the
charitable uh sorry the the Lottery
Commission will just have to look at our
list and see if someone is in good
standing before they'll permit them to
have a license and they may be some back
and forth if we have if they're not in
good standing for one reason or another
um we do also collaborate with the um
with the criminal Bureau we'll
collaborate with the consumer protection
any trust under some circumstances if
there's some Crossover with those two
things
um
and then uh the other large
um piece of what we do is uh all the
organizations that register with us are
required to report to us annually and
what they report is also available to
the public and we review those reports
for a number of things if a charity
appears to be having some kind of
financial trouble we might inquire
what's going on with them
um another thing that we look for very
carefully is Charities are not supposed
are supposed to be operating for the
benefit of that their charitable purpose
and not for the benefit of the directors
and their board of directors so we have
a statute that um that deals with what
are called pecuniary benefits
transactions other states refer to those
as as conflict of interest transactions
which is a term you may be more familiar
with essentially if if a charity engages
in a contract or a payment to a member
of its board of directors there's a
series of of processes that have to be
followed to ensure that that actually is
in the best interest of the charity and
very frequently it is so you may be
someone who you may sit on a board of
directors and also independently own a
heating oil company and in order to
benefit the charity you want to sell
your heating oil to the charity at A Cut
Rate so it actually benefits them you
still make you're still receiving money
off of it but you may not even making a
profit that's all above board but in
order to be sure that it is we require
that um that the that the board vote in
the absence of that person who's in that
contract to make sure that it is in the
best interest if it exceeds a certain
threshold it has to be disclosed to our
office before it happens and they're
also seeing publication in a newspaper
so that the public is aware that this is
happening
um so those are our larger
um
duties we also have a handful of other
activities such as uh when a uh
someone's will includes a donation to a
charity the Probate Court notifies us
will be part of that uh of that
proceeding and once the if there's a
trust established we'll review
accountings of that trust sometimes over
time the the trust will essentially run
out of money it doesn't make sense to
maintain it any longer and will or or it
will appear that the investment of the
fund is not prudent and will want to
make sure that it's being that it's that
the investment process has changed so
that the the trust continues to make
money and continue to support the
purpose that it's set up for
um State and State our municipalities
and counties also all have Trustees of
trust funds so um this is money that is
held in trust by the trustees of trust
funds that for some purpose that someone
donated to the town oftentimes it's to
fund a park or to have a scholarship at
a school those are kind of common types
of trusts that that Trustees of trust
funds and towns will hold and we
um
we receive reports from the towns of the
balances of all of their funds their
investment policies things like that and
we review those to ensure that the that
they're sustainable and also sometimes
to ensure that they are legal so
um oftentimes a trust was set up over a
hundred years ago that is for a purpose
that we that that our state supreme
court has recognized is no longer lawful
the most common example of that is a
scholarship for Protestant students that
would be something that would set up
um pretty commonly a while ago and now
um we know that that our that our
constitution does not allow us to
distinguish between people of different
faiths so our office will get involved
to help the trustees in court to modify
that trust and ensure that it's not
discriminatory on the basis of religion
um our uh our primary focus
um as providing this public information
that I just laid out but also
um recognizing that this is a that
non-profit sector is an 11 billion
dollar
um a year industry in New Hampshire and
that 15 of New Hampshire's Workforce is
employed by a non-profit we recognize
that these are very important entities
um so rather than take enforcement our
first course of action is always
education we don't want to shut down
these Charities that are doing important
work so when we see an issue our first
um the first thing we try to do is to
work with the Charities and most times
what has happened is that people with
very good intentions just didn't quite
understand what they were legally
required to do we set them on the right
track and they keep going it's
occasionally unfortunately the case that
that's that it's not that innocent that
there's some there's theft that there's
misappropriation of funds and those
cases we will take the entities to court
sometimes we'll have a receiver
appointed to take over administration of
the charity until it can be set back on
its its proper footing we don't like to
shut these Charities down if they are
doing important work we like to get the
Bad actors out of the picture and then
put new board members new executive
director in place who can set the
charity on its way
um
the only other things I would mention
are
so we do have a jurisdiction over
conservation easements if they are
donated conservation easements those are
charitable trusts if someone donates a
conservation easement
and we have a process where if uh
someone wants to modify a conservation
easement then they have to involve our
office oftentimes if it's simply to add
more land to a conservation easement or
release a restriction so that it's
actually more protective of the land we
won't have any issue with that but if
someone wants to relocate the conserved
land to a different location or carve
out this piece and add this piece we'll
be very um we'll be closely involved in
that oftentimes that will require us
going to court to get Court approval of
that change and our offices I was always
a party to those proceedings
um so we do all that we have um the
director and myself are the two
attorneys in the office
um we have a financial analyst we have
two investigative paralegals two
paralegals and administrative assistant
um and we also are self-funded so we we
charge fees for the um registrations and
annual reporting we don't get General
funds for any of what we do
um but that's uh pretty much our our
office and I'm happy to take any
questions
uh I guess I forgot about how all these
activities and now I remember what it
was it was pecuniary benefits that's
what that's what because it used to go
to Judiciary and then they and but but
column or his position was if you were
on the board you can't do anything for
an organization and and everybody was
not happy with the decision so they they
brought the bill to Commerce and we
created that pecuniary benefit statute
so
how many nonprofits are there that's a
good question it was on my paper and I
didn't say it so uh so we have
um 13 000 Charities to register with our
office about
um of those about 6 000 are New
Hampshire based so uh and we obviously
we pay more attention to the Charities
that are based in New Hampshire
um we we do review all of the annual
reports we do review all the
registrations
um even which paying a particular
attention to the new hampshire-based
ones
representative Burroughs thank you um I
was curious if you feel that you have
adequate resources to investigate
Charities that may not be following
their own bylaws or violating State
statutes uh there's always a possibility
for more resources um we we do have uh
so we received those um those annual
reports and we do review each one they
typically all come in at once so
um because people follow the IRS
reporting year and so every everybody
who's filing uh
November and and uh March are our big
times so we'll get
10 000 reports at once and so we're
still kind of trying to drag through
that backlog of what had come in in
November
um but yes I think any any additional
resources would certainly help us to to
pick through those we do have to make um
make calls about which of these um
issues that we uncover are are so
important that we need to spend a lot of
time on them and which are are not so uh
I would never say no to more resources
certainly
thank you Representative Vincent thank
you Mr chairman thanks a lot for taking
my question so is charitable trust the
same thing as non-profit or different it
is it is different so uh non-profit is
mostly an IRS distinction you've heard
of 501c Threes there are I think 13 or
14 different classifications
C3 so and we are limited to to c3s which
is the organizations that are organized
for charitable purposes
um there are other non-profit
organizations so 501c4s are ones that
you'll probably have a lot of
interaction with as legislators they're
not chamber of commerces are six or
something like that but for all tons and
purposes when someone says we're a
non-profit right they're a charitable so
they always say are you a 501c3 same
thing
so your office doesn't cover that we we
would cover them if they were soliciting
charitable nations from the public but
not as a matter of course only the 501c
threes thank you very much
right so just make sure you when you
realize you gave a donation to someone
who's not a C3 like to a chamber of
commerce that's not tax deductible it's
not a C3
great thank you very much thank you very
much good job it'd be wonderful if you
could email that to everybody that would
sure it's actually our biennial report
to you from Leslie that's even better
that would be great thank you so much
thank you very much all right uh so
we'll move right on right into
Securities I see
director Linens here
and did I oh she left I saw her
assistant
secretary of state was popped in a
little bit there
so kind of interesting the
um consumer protection division was just
created in the 70s
75 I remember like that's my year I
graduated from high school
um and
and it's interesting they're talking
about how they have these other two
divisions insurance and and uh could
sort of uh the uh charitable trust or
being such old entities so now we're
talking about a relatively young
entities because securities
was created I think just when I got
elected and uh just when I first came in
right at 80. yes that's correct uh Mr
chairman also uh creating exclusive
jurisdiction within those uh agencies
you know to enforce their respective
laws be it Insurance Securities Public
Utilities Commission and yeah it ended
up being added to the to the consumer
protection act as an exemption but yeah
no I I remember
uh well uh when it was first created and
then then uh legally legislatively uh by
bifurcated and then given to the
attorney general excuse me the Secretary
of State's office where before
Securities was actually its own division
in for a short period of time
what's up welcome well thank you Mr
chair
um we really appreciate the opportunity
to present this afternoon before uh the
Commerce Committee to provide you with
an overview of the Bureau of Securities
uh as you know we are organized under uh
the Secretary of State's office
Secretary of State Scanlon uh
accompanying me here today is attorney
Eric Force here who is deputy secretary
with the office as well
as you'll note on the fact sheet that we
just provided to you you'll note that
really our our mission overall is to
protect New Hampshire investors through
effective enforcement of the New
Hampshire Securities act to promote
responsible Capital formation that is
fundraising uh in this security sense
and also to provide for investor
education
we accomplish this really through a
number of ways first being through the
licensing and registration of
Representatives as well as
Securities products conducting of
examinations or what Also may be called
audits of offices enforcement and then
investor education so this afternoon I'd
like to provide you with just a brief
overview of each of those areas answer
any questions that you may have I will
discuss the licensing audit investor Ed
component Eric will discuss the more
really more larger component to the
bureau that is and what we do is
enforcement as well as risk pools
I'd first like to point out before we
begin as you look at that fact sheet
that you'll notice that the numbers
before you may seem relatively large in
terms of the number of registered
representatives and firms and there
really is a good reason for that and
that is because New Hampshire really is
we're talking about Investments New
Hampshire really is a wealth Center when
it when it comes to our our citizenry uh
we have a considerable amount of Assets
in the state we have a much older
population in fact we're the second
oldest population in terms of median age
right behind Maine we're older than
Florida it's hard to believe uh but
still we are a center where there are a
number of retirees and retirees have a
lifetime of assets and that's where
those who are likely to commit
Securities fraud against someone go they
go where the money is and so New
Hampshire can be really and is in many
instances a target for investment fraud
so with regard to the the first
component licensing and registration as
I mentioned we really do have a number
of uh licensees
um there are two really two components
and not I really don't want to bore you
to death with things so if I see anyone
not off I'll I'll just move on but there
the two components are broker-dealers
and investment advisors now
broker-dealers as as I might kind of
characterize it those are individuals
and I know we have a former registry
representative in in the room as well
but a broker dealer representative will
be one who will buy or sell Securities
make recommendations to a client to buy
or sell a security uh for a fee you know
usually there's a commission associated
with that uh and they're essentially
their duty is to make sure that whatever
it is that they are presenting to the
client that they make sure that it it
meets the clients risk tolerance and
investment objective that's really the
two two primary things that they have to
be mindful of when they make that
recommendation so as a as Regulators
we're looking for that whenever there
are any disputed type transactions the
second type of category are investment
advisors and just as the name would
suggest investment advisors offer
investment advice to clients on a
variety of topics not necessarily just
limited to equities but they may be
looking at things such as real estate
their tax situation there may be you
know forward-thinking financial planning
College Planning things of that nature
they tend to look at at a broader
picture however the way in which they
may be compensated there's a number of
different ways but primarily it's based
upon a percentage of the overall assets
that they are overseeing on behalf of
the client so that's those are really
the two means by which Securities are
bought or sold or investment advice uh
is registered
the one distinction though with an
investment advisor is that they are a
fiduciary they are fiduciaries meaning
that whatever it is that they do they
must act in the best interest of the
client above and beyond their own
interests however they may be
compensated uh it must be in the best
interest of the client uh which you know
is is is really a good thing on the uh
broke a dealer side we register as you
can see well over 148 000 registered
reps and uh 1324 firms uh at that's as
of 12 31 of this year on The Advisory
side a smaller population of
5216 investment advisor reps and 28 174
advisory firms and then we also register
Securities products which would be
things such as mutual funds every mutual
fund that is sold in the state of New
Hampshire is registered with the state
of New Hampshire
alt and then we have other types of
offerings that are sold in the state
private certain type of private
offerings and then other Securities uh
real estate investment trusts things
like that they're well over 29 000 of
those registered with our office so when
you add up all of those products and all
of the licensing the bureau will
generate somewhere of actually as of the
end of 1231 uh 41 no 44.1 million
dollars in fees all of which go to the
general fund because we are a
self-funded agency through fines and
penalties only so it really is a sizable
amount to to process
the other component is our audit uh an
examination role and that is that we
will conduct unannounced audits or
reviews at each of those offices on an
unannounced basis uh to to make sure
that they're complying with state law I
am happy to report that the firms in New
Hampshire do a great job
and we may point out certain things that
they could do better some there are
violations which we have to take action
uh against the firm uh however for the
most part they do a terrific job and I
think that's as a result of having a
good solid program of of review with
them and showing them how they can
actually you know maybe perhaps you know
tighten or do better uh with with
certain aspects of their business
the number of Branch offices is
expanding uh in fact a lot of the firms
during covid decided to send most of
their employees home and on the
broker-dealer side a number of of
representatives are actually working
from home now and so the question is are
those branch offices and should we be
visiting those homes we do on the
investment advisor side because many
work from home but that could very well
expand our our audit uh function but
we're not necessarily asking and I
expect representative Burroughs may ask
me the question looking for additional
resources we're going to try to work
within the constraints you know that we
have in in terms of Staffing to address
that
one of the more exciting parts of what
we do as investor education and it
really is of an important part of our
mission our Focus really is on fraud
prevention Ed Financial education is is
pretty broad but when you focus on
investing uh our message is to say to
invest uh in in a safe and prudent
manner
our our victims are just as just as you
might uh uh think and it's really what
what it's it's the same story on the
licensing side uh our victims are those
who are older that they have a lifetime
of assets retirees and fraudsters will
come into the state of New Hampshire
because they know that that's where the
money is and so New Hampshire because we
are a wealth Center we could also be a a
target for investment fraud uh and uh in
order to combat that it's really comes
down to investor education so what do we
do we do a considerable amount of
Outreach to seniors uh particularly
organizations including lifelong
Learning Centers uh we uh such as Let's
osher uh uh which is organized through
Dartmouth College uh the Oli program
which is administered through Granite
State College as well as independent
living organizations they're all prime
targets and so that's where we really
need to and have been consistently
educating the public we also reach out
to a number of Civic organizations such
as a rotary or fraternal organizations
as well as interestingly other other
organizations more recently I did a
presentation to the Joint New Hampshire
Society of Engineers which has nothing
to do with Securities but they do have
assets and they can be a Target uh so we
try to reach that segment of the of the
population as well
under the direction of Secretary of
State Scanlon this past fall we really
introduced a really interesting investor
Ed outreach program which I've made many
of you I hopefully have heard uh in in
it's called invest smart New Hampshire
which is our logo is on that sheet that
you have in front of you
uh the uh the program included in
creating and really an investor-centric
type website called
investmart.nh.gov which I would
encourage you to visit uh it has all
kinds of very interesting information
Geared for first-time investors how do
you select an investment advisor what
are the questions that you ask an
investment advisor when you first or or
registered rep when you're first meeting
with them people there you just don't
know what to what to do or say so there
are tips there how to identify uh and
ask what what questions you should be
asking of them in terms of how your the
relationship should or could work we
also provide information about the
typical perpetrator what are some of the
typical signs of a perpetrator somebody
who may be taking advantage of you uh
their traits and then we focus on
resources for seniors and then other
things which reaching the more younger
generation a podcast series and then
resources for teachers as well as a
printable resource and printed resource
which uh attorney forse here if I can
just ask you I hate to have you passing
these around
these we just developed a New Hampshire
investor guide for those returning
Representatives you may have received
one in your mailbox during I think what
I shouldn't call it veto day but that's
all I know it is to be and it was in
your mailbox but for some of the newer
representatives to this committee
you'll you'll find that this is a a
really nice source of information on how
to invest wisely first off it's
available to the general public at no
cost in fact if you would like
additional copies my contact information
is on that sheet you can just ask me
what whatever it is that you need in
terms of quantity
the guide covers a number of really
interesting topics such as the selection
of an advisor but what's what are
investments and why should you why
should you invest
um some of the typical scams or frauds
that may be conducted or you have to be
mindful of and uh and a host of other
topics which I think is useful this is
available both in English and Spanish as
well so if you have a population of
Spanish speaking
individuals let us know and we'll we'll
get those to you as well so that that
comprises the the new invest smart and H
type program but I would also encourage
you if if you uh happen to know of or if
you are part of a group in your District
that would like to to have the bureau
come and speak to an organization to
talk about safe investing or more than
happy to do that we'll provide each
participant obviously with a copy of of
our investor guide and try to tailor our
presentation to your group it doesn't
matter what it is nor whether it's
daytime or evening please just reach out
to us and we're certainly available
to present at this point I'd like to
turn it over to Eric who will talk about
our enforcement component as well as
risk pools
thank you Barry
I'll keep this microphone a little
further away from me because I talk loud
enough as it is so
so again my name is Eric Force here I've
been with the Securities Bureau for 13
years now and
primarily working in enforcement
the best part of our job is being able
to help New Hampshire consumers big or
small we have people come in who have
lost money that is a small sliver of
their portfolio but they're troubled by
what happened or it's their entire life
savings
be it 10 grand or over a million dollars
we treat everybody the same we we take
complaints from consumers and the best
part of our job is helping those
consumers out primarily recovering if we
can losses that may have been incurred
as a result of violating our law but
bringing Bad actors to Justice I'll let
go what Barry said the firms in New
Hampshire do a great job the people in
New Hampshire investing on behalf of New
Hampshire residents do a great job
but not all of them and the ones that
don't end up
in our enforcement unit so I've been
there 13 years
we we operate
on complaints primarily so we receive
complaints from New Hampshire consumers
or people outside of New Hampshire doing
business with New Hampshire consumers
we primarily receive them from consumers
themselves
sometimes we receive referrals from
other state agencies or federal agencies
but most often a case started with our
office starts with somebody walking in
or calling and talking about a problem
they have with a broker or an investment
advisor or just somebody selling them
Securities because you don't necessarily
have to be licensed to be selling
securities to New Hampshire residents so
they come in all forms
on average and this is just an average
we have about 70 investigations a year
mostly emanating from complaints but
sometimes they're tips sometimes we see
issues in the marketplace and we can
bring enforcement matters related to
that but there's about 70 or so in the
pipeline every year
those we also have about 40 enforcement
actions that we end up filing every year
so I'm a very big some are very small
some of them are very defunct companies
that have no assets left and it's come
to our attention because it's been a
total fraud that's been well reported
everywhere some of them we help
uncover and we help reveal
but we have about 40
cases a year
usually they're administrative
conditioner that provides a wide range
of tools to the enforcement unit to
bring relief and expose exposed frauds
even Ponzi schemes in New Hampshire
we've uncovered some of those but we
usually bring administrative cases but
we also have the legislature has granted
us wide authority to go to Superior
Court and bring relief in Superior Court
so we will bring primarily
administrative cases but we do go to
Superior Court to freeze assets or to
um and force compliance with our orders
or our subpoenas so we're in court as
well
a lot of our cases are sales practice
violations a broker
broke our law in engaging in a
transaction that would say unsuitable or
unfair to the consumer
call them minor but those resultant
losses that really harm people so we
have those types of sale practice
violation cases but it really runs to
Gambit we have
um total complete fraud cases as well as
the other side of that that Spectrum
whether they're using online advertising
or print people are responding to ads
from fraudsters online or in print and
losing significant amounts of money and
some of our a lot of our cases are in
that world as well but it really runs
the Gambit the um cases types of cases
we see often time and time again is
promissory note cases a note is a
security there are some exemptions and
there are some carbons that apply but
generally a node is a security so when
people borrow money from somebody
particularly when they're borrowing that
money to engage in an Enterprise to turn
a profit for that lender it's a security
we have those types of cases we have
cases where people will
open up an LLC and sell interest in
their LLC to their friends Neighbors
random people online
those are securities so we have the
types of cases that are not your typical
investment advisor and broker dealer
cases we have plenty of those but we
also have half our world is also those
other types of Securities transactions
that I just told you about I'm happy to
talk about further
we routinely work with criminal
authorities you heard Brandon garad from
the Consumer Protection Bureau we have a
great relationship with the Attorney
General's office and we work closely
with them and and making sure that
people who violate our Securities laws
because there are criminal components to
it get brought to justice so we'll we'll
regularly meet with them at the AG's
office Brandon's unit will engage in
referrals that anything we think might
be a crime we bring it over to them
sometimes it's not a Securities
violation a Securities fraud and they'll
charge it as theft but oftentimes when
you violate the Securities act and you
committed Securities fraud
you've also committed theft so we are
proud in our track record in working
with the Attorney General's office and
other other uh criminal prosecutors
we've worked on some federal cases with
the U.S attorney's office and the FBI
and um we actually have some great cases
with the County attorneys as well so we
have uh regular working relationships
with all the criminal authorities and
are you know in the past
10 years or so we've brought I think a
record number of Securities cases that
have gone criminal we've really brought
people to Justice in that realm and it's
I think sent sent an appropriate message
and I've personally worked on a lot of
those cases and testified in grand
juries and and we've been very
successful knock on wood in Superior
Court and on criminal cases because it's
hard to explain to a jury and jury
instructions uh Securities so that's one
hurdle that we're
we've done we've done well on
um
we also routinely work with the
Securities and Exchange Commission as
you can imagine a lot of the cases we
look at and the transactions we're
looking at cross state lines and so we
regularly work with and bring cases
I wouldn't say joint because they're a
separate agency but we concurrent cases
in uh parallel cases all the time and so
we have a great working relationship
with Boston regional office of the SEC
and we routinely work on cases with them
referrals back and forth
we have a great working relationship
with the banking and insurance
departments here in the state we meet
with them regularly I pick up the phone
and talk to them weekly there's a lot of
cases that have both banking insurance
or Insurance Banking and securities
components so by Statute we regularly
meet but more often than required by
Statute we're talking and we're
regularly engaging each other because
there's a lot of uh particularly with
insurance over overlap
um
we routinely work with our neighboring
states of Massachusetts Vermont uh Maine
and other states in New England on cases
because again a lot of these
Brokers investment advisors products are
being sold across state lines and we we
work together to bring uh
to to bring those to a conclusion as
well we regularly bring in about one to
two million dollars in fines and
penalties as Barry alluded we're a
self-funded agency the registration fees
licensing fees
and the fees that Barry spoke about uh
are directly to the general fund we
operate uh self-funded on the fines and
penalties that we uh administer against
these agencies every every year uh
against these firms and brokers
not all of them pay it and we also are
collection agency of sorts we definitely
have judgments against people for
victims in New Hampshire that we are
every year we seem to add more to the
debt list of of consumers and victims in
New Hampshire that owed money we
continue to pursue that but we still are
able to stay self-funded with the
penalties that we're able to uh get from
firms that can pay
um
we regularly provide assistance that
don't really rise to enforcement but we
get calls from consumers all the time uh
they can't get access to their accounts
we quickly help them with that their
broker's not calling them back we
quickly help them with that I found the
stock certificate I'm an administrator
of an estate and I found this in the
bottom drawer is this worth anything
those are always fun we Chase those down
but we do provide that uh that help to
Consumers uh on a regular basis as well
we're heavily involved in the North
American Securities administrators
Association that's the conglomerate of
State Securities Regulators in North
America uh we continue to hold
leadership roles there and help other
states and work with other states
through that National Organization and
they've they've done a great job for New
Hampshire they they help us bring Global
cases that we couldn't do by ourselves
and The Leverage of other states coming
together with NASA and not the NASA
you're thinking of with this NASA is is
a great a great benefit to the state we
continue to play a role there
we all we also regulate pooled Risk
Management Programs as Barry alluded to
that's RSA 5B those are when political
subdivisions come together and pool
money for the purchase of health
insurance property Casualty Insurance
and different insurances it's a statute
that allows these communities to come
together to pool their money because
there's always a better deal to be had
when you pull your money together and
you're a larger group especially with
the tax benefits provided by RSA 5B so
they are significant there's five pools
in New Hampshire they annually file with
us and we continue to monitor monitor
and ensure their compliance with RSA 5B
and that's a big role in our office and
continues to be a big role and sort of
the other facet of our office they
provide a great benefit to the New
Hampshire political subdivisions and it
takes a lot of resources to monitor
their compliance and and making sure
that Surplus is returned as they're
supposed to under the law we can talk
about this further but we've had a
number of
cases had gone to the Supreme Court uh
um enforcing compliance with RSA 5B that
we've been successful in returning tens
of millions of dollars to communities uh
in in the form of surplus that should
have been returned a long time ago
that's another big part of our office
where the enforcement team is
approximately give or take six attorneys
but they have varying functions in the
office with examinations and Audits and
so they don't all spend full time on
enforcement but give or take we have six
attorneys uh working every day and
helping New Hampshire investors which is
something I'm personally really proud
about having done for the past 13 years
and and uh anytime there's any
legislation before this committee or
before the legislature you'll hear me
and Barry pounding that consumer
protection drum uh we are a consumer
protection agency and we will carefully
review legislation
we recognize benefits of new products
and new ideas but we have to always
pound that drum because it's important
products are changing every day I'm sure
we're going to see legislation and we
have seen legislation and we'll continue
to try to protect our investigative
Authority we should be able to continue
to investigate and securities is such a
broad sweeping term
um it's meant to Encompass all types of
activities that are changing every day
and we'll try to continue to safeguard
that Authority and that's where you'll
see us uh this year and years to come
before this legislature
um
that's all I've got on my I'm happy to
take any questions
I talk fast so slow me down and ask me
to repeat I'd be happy to do so
representative Burroughs thank you
um through the fines that you collect
does that ever go towards making
investors whole who have been defrauded
is that where it goes
so the fines and penalties are what pays
our expenses of our office any
difference gets poured over to the
general fund which happens I think every
single year that I've been there we've
had it but no the fines and penalties do
not go
but we do get orders for restitution and
we do we've returned I think over 70
million dollars in the past 15 years to
um actually representative I I would
venture to say it's probably over 125
million now at this point in terms of
restitution so where's the source of
that money if it's not from fines to for
repayment is that money that you've
taken back we have collect we would have
collected from uh firms
um uh for repayment to aggrieved
investors is the last question is it
ever possible for a group of aggrieved
investors to seek legislative response
for repayment as was done with the Ponzi
scheme uh there was as I recall in the
in the case of Financial Resources
mortgage uh there was uh in fact I think
legislation had passed for funding for
that
um however we you know it's been our
contention I could see representative
upon
um that the issue there involved
mortgages
um and uh uh that it was intended to
provide restitution to those who had uh
invested actually in mortgages as
opposed to Securities thanks
and if I could add to that a lot of our
cases in the enforcement unit if they do
resolve without a hearing they will
resolve with restitution back to
Consumers and there's plenty of cases I
have that the fines and penalties have
gone unpaid and any money we do get we
put towards the restitution first it's
important to pay back New Hampshire
investors as much as we can and we're
cognizant of that when we settle cases
and we make sure that these you know
these big broker dealers and these big
Investment Advisors
are paying restitution are paying its
restitution discouragement or rescission
and and
it's one of our primary forms of relief
people still have their private right of
action and we remind them of that but we
do everything we can to get money back
to uh consumers in New Hampshire that
have lost money as a result of violating
our law
yeah restitution was always in their
statute I didn't we didn't have to add
that where we did for insurance and
banking it was always there and that
decision the frm decision was that was
really a banking problem rather than a
Securities problem
and there's a book you can read all
about it that's right unfortunately he's
passed away or if we wrote the book but
hey Mark and
okay any other questions see none thank
you very much gentlemen thank you thank
you very much appreciate it
well on your way out can you tell liquor
to come on in
thank you thank you okay
let me move
okay
foreign
I don't know
if they don't you forget that yeah
okay
did you do any handouts
thank you
good half
way that's cool
it's quite all right Mr chairman thank
you very much for having us
I've been there
my mic was off
go ahead okay
so good afternoon everyone good
afternoon members of the committee Mr
chairman I'm Joseph Malik I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission with me today is our CFO Tina
demirs our CEO James Vera Lori Piper our
chief marketing officer and Mark
armaganian who is the chief of
enforcement
so what we've prepared today is just a
some light reading and an overview of
what the Liquor Commission does
so on page two you'll see that we are
one of 17 control states in the country
after prohibition the federal government
allowed states to decide whether they
want to be open or closed States and New
Hampshire was one of the very wise
states to take the the liquor control to
themselves and we're the only state that
does the
wholesale and the retail of liquor we do
have brokers in the state as you'll
notice on page three the three-tier
system
but we're the only state that has
exclusive Liquor and Wine in the states
there is other states that do some of
their retail but we are the One You're
the only state that does it exclusively
so
on page four you'll see the value of the
three-tier system
uh and basically the value of the
three-tier system for us is that those
the retail outlets that the consumers go
into are also control venues for alcohol
so we have the profits from those areas
but we also have control of the product
from when it enters the state into our
warehouse in Bow our 241
000 square foot Warehouse that we're now
adding on to and we have a 20-year
contract with DHL to run that warehouse
for us
on page five you'll notice the
competition the major competition for us
obviously comes from Massachusetts uh 50
percent of our sales are cross-border
sales 23 of those sales come from
Massachusetts our biggest competitor in
Massachusetts and around the country as
you'll see on page five is Total Wine
you can see how governor Patrick passed
the law in 2011. they they took the tax
off of alcohol they changed the amount
of licenses that they can hold and
they're raising the tap the cap again uh
in 2022 we don't know exactly where it
will be but we feel that I'm sorry in
2024 it but we feel that it will
probably be uh 11 stores Total Wine
being the biggest competitor and on page
six you'll see the mammoth business that
Total Wine is they're 5 billion in
Revenue in 2020. they have 245 stores in
27 States 10 stores in New England they
have many many employees across the
country and they're adding two two more
stores in Massachusetts to their current
six they'll be adding two more this year
so basically inside of the 45 495 belt
they have they have all of their stores
one store is in Southborough that
exceeds the 495 belt but they've
concentrated everything from that point
east so where the population is and
obviously where our consumers come from
they've concentrated on that they're a
behemoth in the business they do a lot
of a lot of marketing they don't beat us
in price
all the time but they do beat us in
price sometimes we are we don't do any
private labeling which that's what they
do they do a bait and switch Market we
deal in name brand products and name
brand prices we don't have any off
Brands and we don't have any private
Brands and Total Wine is a private brand
retailer so at this point our CFO Tina
Demers will bring you through the
operational overview and we'll be happy
to answer questions at any time thank
you
good afternoon
so our introduction the important thing
to note is that the Liquor Commission is
self-funded
we don't use any general funds to
operate our business we generated 771
million in gross sales in FY 22
operating 67 retail outlets two
warehouses one which is in Concord and
the other is the DHL Warehouse in Beau
on page nine are statutory duties is to
optimize profits maintain controls
effective inefficient operations and
provide service to customers
were governed under title 13 the
alcoholic beverages which is Chapters
175 to 180.
our organizational structure we have
three divisions that report to the
chairman and the Deputy Commissioner the
division of enforcement uh the division
of administration and the division of
marketing and Merchandising
each one has subunits the office of the
commission the primary goals are to
increase sales and profitability
the division of enforcement is
responsible for enforcing alcohol and
tobacco laws youth access to alcohol and
tobacco and providing licenses education
and support to over 6 100 licensees the
division of administration is made up of
a finance department doit Human
Resources auditing inventory control and
legal services and then you have the
division of marketing and Merchandising
which includes marketing merchandising
advertising and our retail outlets
the next eight slides I'm going to bring
you through a little Financial overview
of the commission on the first one uh
net profit history you'll see that we've
produced or the commission has produced
over 4.3 billion in net profit from its
Inception in 1935 to fiscal year 2020.
the uh the chart on the bottom for net
profit is the history from 2013 to 2020.
you'll see that the growth in 2021 was
significant so we have a decrease in FY
22 which still is in line with the
regular Trend in history when you look
at it pre-pandemic
the next slide Revenue Trends in
transfer language this one is important
because we just want to make sure
everybody is aware where our funds are
transferred to so there are two rsas
governing Revenue transfers that are
prior to our transfer to the general
fund
the first RSA is 176.16 and this is
calculated bellystone five percent of
our prior year gross profits and that is
transferred
to the alcohol fund and the other one is
RSA
126aa and this one is not in our Revenue
plan because during the year the fiscal
year HHS has to calculate to ensure that
they have sufficient non-federal funds
in the granted Advantage Health Care and
trust fund and at that point when they
ask for additional funds we transferred
last year it was eight million dollars
this year it's around 7 million
the next slide is our revenue and
expenses it's a five-year history our FY
22 Revenue as we said has decreased but
is in a normal trend of our historic
growth our expenses are consistent with
our expense to revenue ratio it's around
30 percent
on slide 15 the revenue history by
category our revenue is broken down into
three sources you have beer tax and
permits the liquor and wine revenue and
then we have other Revenue which
includes licensing Lottery direct
shipping permits and other miscellaneous
Revenue
slide 16 is a history of beer tax in
gallonage as with the sale of alcohol
beer tax had an increase in FY 21 but is
back to the normal levels at in FY 22 at
12.6 million or 41.9 million gallons
on slide 17 it's our sales by customer
type and by category so you'll see on
the top line that retail is 383 million
or 50 percent of our sales wine for
retail is 173 million or 22.6 percent so
our total retail is 556 million or 72.7
percent of our sales and if you look at
the two pie charts they're broken down
by Spears and by wine by those
categories so you'll see that retail
Spirits are 85 percent of that category
and on this wine side the retail is
about 55 percent
foreign
the next slide
I'm sorry on premise is a restaurant
so where you go in and you consume
on-premise and off-premises the grocery
stores where you buy the product to take
it off premise
uh the next is uh the top 15 Outlets
so the top 15 Outlets equate for 51
percent of our sales for a total of
305.7 million
and in that we have seven of our
state-owned stores that are in the top
15 and they equate to 150.6 million of
that
and this next slide is um the agency
stores we have three agency licenses uh
one was issued in 2003 and then two of
them that were issued in 2005. uh
you have two in the North country and
one in the southern part of the state
and you'll see that there were no sales
for the arrow location because they are
under construction due to a loss of the
building from a fire
and with that we're on to the marketing
and Merchandising
what is an agency store
there was a time
when the Liquor Commission was looking
to kind of diversify
what they did
mainly because they weren't as
profitable as they should be and they
didn't really run the outlets we didn't
have a brand we didn't have a look we
didn't have a feel that's all changed
and at that point The Liquor Commission
had given out these licenses to private
retailers private entrepreneurs to run
stores in areas that the Liquor
Commission didn't feel they could be
profitable
thus Pittsburgh arrow and Greenville at
the time
obviously that cross-border creep is is
important to us but that store is there
and and we uh you know we quantify that
license by it's been there a long time
we haven't really uh we haven't put out
an agency store license in many many
years uh the Pittsburgh agency store
went out for bid last year because it
was sold and you cannot transfer an
agency store license it has to be it has
to be an RFP and it has to be bid on so
it ended up in the same location in
Pittsburgh and young store where it's
always been
thanks you're welcome
good afternoon
I'm going to take you through the
marketing merchandising distribution and
Warehouse
so we'll start on page 21. currently we
operate 68 retail outlets around the
state and we have as mentioned before uh
two warehouses our DHL Warehouse in Beau
and our Concord warehouse and our
Concord Warehouse is state-owned
um we we have our state-owned and New
Hampshire made products there which
allows our New Hampshire products to
remain bailment free and bailment is
really just another word for rent and so
we do not charge bailment in that
warehouse for our New Hampshire made
products
merchandising is also part of the
division along with negotiating prices
pricing and purchasing of all of our
products for on and off-prem and of
course advertising and communication
fall under that division as well
I'm just going to step in here just for
a moment to to let you know that bailman
is a is if as Laurie said it's a rent
it's a fee charge to the Brokers that
store the product in the warehouse in
Bow The Liquor Commission in the state
does not own the product in the
warehouse in Beau it's owned by the
Brokers and it's owned by the suppliers
and they pay DHL a rent in order to
store that product there The Liquor
Commission does not take ownership of
that product until the truck is loaded
and the door is closed that's when we
own the product but I thought New
Hampshire
and New Hampshire New Hampshire made
product is stored in our warehouse in
Concord bailment free so anybody that
produces in New Hampshire wine Winery or
Distillery is allowed to keep their
product in Concord in our warehouse at
no charge to them so bailment free
thank you sorry thank you chairman thank
you
as of December 31st we have nine
state-owned Outlook locations along with
59 least outlets and we have 27 of those
Outlets that are available for in-store
and curbside pickup
on page 23 there's just a quick list of
our state-owned outlets and it's
important to note that a state our owned
Outlets account for over
um 164 million dollars or 27 of total
sales
kitchen
we have some Outlet changes I'm on page
24 so since 2012 we've renovated
relocated or constructed 40 new outlet
locations in more than 35 communities
and this year we opened a new outlet in
Manchester range in Concord and new
outlet locations are in the works for
both Nashua and Derry
The Liquor Commission with the guidance
of its consultant H NTB
and the nhdoj continue to redevelop
to state-owned properties located
alongside Interstate 95 North and South
in Hampton these will be very similar to
what you find at our hooks at locations
currently
on page 25
we have our Claremont Outlet
and it went from 5600 square feet to
over 10 000 square feet and a sales
increase of 0.8 percent
our next Outlet is ringe on page 26.
again an increase in square footage to
10 325 with the sales increase of over
23 percent
that was not all mine purchases
27 is a beautiful photo of our Concord
Outlet at exit 17 we went from 4 000
square feet to over 13 000 square feet
with an increase in sales of 2.9 percent
for that outlet
on page 28 one of our newest Outlets of
Manchester Gold Street over 12 000
square feet outlet and the FY 23
year-to-date sales 2.2 million dollars
for that location
I'll talk a little bit about our
marketing or what is uh what you
probably best know as marketing
Communications
and some of our goals so through our
marketing we secure products we manage
the merchandising and of course we
promote the products really our goal is
to bring the best products and values to
our customers through a really positive
shopping experience we want to engage
with our customers online and in Outlet
we support our New Hampshire businesses
we want to position ourselves as Best in
Class and we do this in a few different
ways we host uh world-class events
and that attracts top industry
professional professionals we engage
celebrities when we can and that kind of
heightens our engagement with customers
they love that and we also use Cutting
Edge marketing tactics we provide
excellent customer service and we try to
innovate in all areas on a continual
basis
on page 30 talk a little bit about our
web and our Ecom our website is uh very
robust it's a great place for our
customers to go and learn more about our
products and availability we have over
125 000 visitors a month to that webpage
which is really great
we did start our curbside in in-store
pickup
when the pandemic hit and people were no
longer wanting to go and visit retail
outlets and Shop we very quickly got up
to speed with a curbside and in-store
pickup option that program has been
doing really well we currently have 27
locations across the state where you can
use our pickup or curbside service
and uh your order can be ready in 90
minutes I mean that's pretty pretty
quick and you can choose to go in or
just pull up to the curb and currently
uh we
have 3.1 million in sales that was for
FY 22 that's a 15 increase over fy21 and
since the Inception in September 2020
we're at 7.6 million year to date since
we implemented which is really great our
top stores for curbside are Salem West
Lebanon and Hampton North
on page 31 just a quick overview of some
of our in-outlet activations we we
currently publish a sales flyer every
month and when we can as mentioned
before we like to take advantage of our
celebrities our customers love it they
love learning about their products
and a couple of photos there at the
bottom you can see some of our
merchandising in our Outlets and some of
our really powerful displays they are
very shoppable they're eye-catching they
support our highest gross profit profit
products and our customers just love
them
on page 32
just a broad brush about our monthly
sales every month we have a sale a
different sale and here's just a quick
look at how it's supported through all
of our marketing channels so no matter
where you go and what kind of medium you
consume you'll learn about our monthly
sales which is really great
on the next page 33
just a little bit about our social media
everybody's online now everybody has
social media accounts and our email
marketing as well we have a very robust
strategy you can see some of our
followers there on our three main social
channels and we do send out seven
targeted emails every single month to
different subscribers we have over 25
000 subscribers
on page 34 this is just an example of
one of our brand building campaigns this
was our keep it local which supported
our New Hampshire Wineries and
distilleries and we had a great kickoff
event we discounted the New Hampshire
products they had prominent display in
our Outlets we built a specialized web
presence where customers could go and
learn more about each of those
distilleries and wineries an interactive
map if you will and also supported that
with social media
on page 35 a little bit about our Google
reviews we do watch them we do pay
attention to what people are saying
through Google and we do have 91 of our
reviews over time our four and five star
ratings and you can see just a quick
table there of how many have come in for
that time period
question now
Joe
I have one more oh if you if you like
okay
and uh page 36 you can see here is just
kind of a collection of charitable
contributions
um we do love supporting our local
charities and since 2015 we've worked
with suppliers and Brokers to raise
nearly 3.5 million dollars for
non-profits in the area
that brings me to my last slide so I'm
happy to take questions
representative Herbert
um just a couple of things do you do you
do any television advertising we don't
currently we do have video and most
people will go to YouTube to watch the
video and we also put that in all of our
Outlets we have video screens throughout
our Outlets so we do video but not
broadcast TV at this at this point okay
and I like that
call further question
yes
um
just a comment I I like that that you
picked up on the uh you know call in the
order and you can come pick it up
because I I know the grocery stores are
all doing that yes yep it's very popular
now and you know so we're seeing
business come back people do want to
come into the retail outlets and Shop
but there are some people that just feel
more comfortable pulling up to the curb
and getting their their purchase that
way so we want to accommodate everyone
who wants to do that this is a question
um do you have any issues with what's I
think it's called shrink
it I have heard that no people are
walking out of the stores it's been I
was that I was told that it was has been
a problem recently and I was just
wondering if that was accurate or if you
uh if if it's a noticeable problem
well in certain locations it is but it
still remains a very minute number it's
one half of one percent of our sales so
it's a very small number uh the chief
can speak to it a little bit when we
come when he comes up but it's certainly
something that
that has grown in recent years
thank you
uh well that stirred some questions
okay I just want to make a comment about
local New Hampshire made I think you
guys have done a great job over the last
10 15 years with promoting local because
I years ago they really had an issue
especially the wineries with shelf space
in the stores and you've done it great
this this committee got the commission
to move the rack up to the front to the
store when they have their own section
as well so thank you very much so
representative
I had a question
um as to a lot of times I will see as a
restaurant tour I will see people
pulling up and I will see them filling
their entire Vans full of liquor with
mass plates
um what exactly is is if anything being
done to curtail that kind of behavior
well there's there's nothing being done
to curtail it it's uh fair enough
it's so so this has been an ongoing
issue obviously we did have um one of
our counselors
it was it was involved in in accusations
in the store I myself did see uh in
range I did see a North Carolina license
plate and people loading it up and and
when I walked by they they you know gave
me a very strange look and maybe because
I had a state plate and I drove in but
um the the obviously the the big issue
was the ten thousand dollar you know in
terms of cash you know versus credit
card but
and and just to follow up on that Mr
chairman if I may The Liquor Commission
through the doj asked for an opinion
letter from the IRS and the IRS wrote us
an opinion letter that the Liquor
Commission is within their realm of
doing business within the state of New
Hampshire uh regardless of the amount of
sales that someone from out of state
buys right but I do notice that the
there used to be a big pile of a certain
uh
uh was it a whiskey no it was a Hennessy
that was Hennessy that was piled up by
the door uh and because range were a
Border Town uh but that pile is gone now
so that that either Hennessey's cut us
off or the pile is just back farther
takes change and times change so yes
that
this this question is based on my own
ignorance and I have wanted to ask it
forever and now I have a captive group
that can answer the question and it's a
silly little question when you have a
wine store
that's just dedicated to selling wine
are they licensed through the state of
New Hampshire or are they some other
kind of thing no they're licensed
through the state representative all
licenses in the state of New Hampshire
go through the The Liquor Commission I
believe they're 6400 licenses so they're
not one of these state agency things
that's a different thing that's correct
they are a private retail wine Outlet
right so so technically they're an
off-premise licensee correct so that
they would you know and I remember in
the old days we used to have beer stores
but you know they've gone the way of
Hannaford's Market Basket you know no
that they weren't successful anymore but
yes we do have a handful of wine
exclusive stores and you could
open one yourself and be a licensing
okay
and then representative thank you Mr
chairman I
um I just have a question I I don't want
to rain on anybody's parade but when I
go into get a bottle of wine which I do
frequently uh in the front of the store
these always these wines that are hugely
discounted
but they're wines that I don't know
about I mean is is this some sort of a
price switch or are these really quality
wines every once in a while I buy one
but it's nothing I ever heard of are
these over socks from Italy or something
like that
well if you're talking about the price
Buster program or power by program yeah
Price Plus yeah
The Liquor Commission the power buy
program is something that we've we've
done in the last seven or eight years
that we've asked Distributors we've
asked the Brokers is there wines out
there that are quality number one
regardless of where they're from but
they have to be discounted by 50 percent
to be into that program so that's why
you're seeing high quality wines at 50
percent discounted rates
thank you you're welcome Representative
Vincent
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I was under the
assumption that uh it was 12 this one 12
percent
uh for prevention and treatment and not
five percent is there any truth to that
it's five percent it's five percent
okay thank you
okay so it I'm sorry representative
sharing all this really interesting
information
I have a very basic question so on page
18 it shows state-owned locations and I
was curious what are the other kind of
locations for example Seabrook I
represent the Seacoast so what would the
Seabrook location be categorized as it's
a state it's a state-run location but we
don't own the property representative we
have a landlord tenant releasing
releasing the location release that
property from Market Basket owns that
the state runs the yes we we have a
25-year lease there but it's a real
estate underneath faith that you're
leasing correct and the interesting
story the history goes when I first got
on this committee most of those leases
were below Market leases that the
landlord literally gave gave it away to
have to have us there in their locations
representative Yemen thank you Mr
chairman thank you for testifying uh
presenting to us
there was a period uh during and after
the pandemic where Staffing was an issue
and store hours were cut back could you
give us the latest update on where those
issues stand
well we're still down in staff by we
have a percentage for
a 14 vacancy rate right now 48 48 open
positions uh what we've done in House
Bill 2 is we've put in two two trailers
in in the house bill one that allows us
to have a incentive program uh in in 20
uh 20 2011 under Governor Lynch we wrote
an incentive program into House Bill 2
which was passed but we've never used it
we've never had a reason to use it uh
now we're we're putting that incentive
program into play and uh we hope to be
starting it at the end of this year we
also put in uh
I'm sorry the end of last year I'm still
working in last year a little jet lag
and we've also asked for separate
a separate
lines in our budget to be able to
reclassify our people in the stores
because our employees in the stores are
quite frankly woefully underpaid to the
percentage of retail in the state so
what we've asked in House Bill 2 is that
pay scale so we're allowed we're asking
to be allowed to bring that pay scale up
and reclassify those folks so they are
paid an average that is paid within the
state so yes we are still understaffed
not as bad as we were at the time that
we cut some hours and cut some stores
but our pay scale is still greatly
beneath what we feel that it should be
in order to attract employees to come to
work for this so so what is the starting
salary
12.36 an hour
neither are we but we're doing our best
to to make those changes and the
governor has supported I I worked with
the governor's office on the incentive
program uh you know we went through a
few iterations and we based it on
additional sales so we feel that the the
employees will be bonused on the
additional sales so that's a great start
for us
to be able to do it
I don't disagree
represent Ammon first just a quick
follow-up thank you uh the incentive
program could you just give us the high
level of what that is
well the incentive program will be based
on a percentage of sales growth so uh if
if we grow the sales by a certain
percentage the employees will share 10
of that growth will be distributed
amongst amongst the stores by region so
there's seven regions and we have seven
supervisors so some regions can hit it
where others won't so it will be our
idea was in doing it that the regions
would work together the stores in that
region would work together to lift
everyone's boat and lift the sails and
everyone in that region would enjoy
those additional sales and it would
create a little bit of competition
between the stores in order to increase
sales in all areas it's it could be
different a store in the North country
can gain as much as as an agency I mean
a store in this in the southern part of
the state given by region
so it's ten percent of the increase
and obviously
that
in addition to changing the pay scale
and changing the descriptions of those
jobs should be more than the incentive
that we need to hire additional
employees and keep our employees that
are in place paid at a scale that we
feel is is more in line with other
retailers like-minded retailers
representative Herbert
um
how when is this going to occur I mean
in terms of the
12 bucks is
grossly underpaid for sure but
um is there a schedule as to when this
these things will hit the incentive
program started in January so we started
it now and it will go it'll be paid
every quarter so it will end in March
and then we'll be we're making the first
payouts in June it's not so 90 days
after that so employees will see those
first checks in June of this year but in
the base pay raise is that something the
base pay raises
part of the budget is prior to the
budget
okay
thank you very much you're welcome very
informative thank you
now to the best title in the state of
New Hampshire
chief enforcer
thank you Mr chairman you make me sound
like a pro wrestler
um
for for those of you who have been here
hello uh honorable committee members
those new members congratulations
um this is a great committee and and we
get a lot of great work done and you'll
see me a lot with my partner Aiden Moore
so
um
I'm sorry
he's still around yes he's probably
watching us right now we gave him a
little plug there's no doubt he's
watching it
um
first we'll start off with our mission
and our vision statement
um this is very important to us the way
we do business this administration's
been together for six years
um we have changed the way we've done
business so anything you know prior to
that know that we're doing business
differently and we're doing it better so
the division of enforcement licensing
education is dedicated to educating the
public consumers students and license
holders about state liquor laws statutes
along with Legal Financial social and
health risks of abusing alcohol and
that's very important to us
furthermore the division administers
laws in a fair and uniform manner to
work toward the elimination of underage
drinking thereby reducing the problems
associated with underage consumptions
and and that is something that we see
quite often that we're working really
diligently diligently on with our high
schools and I'll talk more about that as
we move on
um we have a three-prong approach as we
look at
um uh our enforcement licensing and
education from an enforcement standpoint
we inspect and regulate manufacture and
just just distribution and retail sales
of alcohol and and tobacco products from
a licensing purview we provide guidance
to business through the application
licensure process and I could tell you
that we just had yesterday one of our
licensing Specialists go out into the
field and actually sit down with a
prospective license a and help them
through the process because they didn't
have a computer so this is a customer
service is very uh a very high standard
to us and what we provide to our
prospective licensees education
we partner with stakeholders on
awareness education of alcohol laws
administering the rules and responsible
business practices and at the end of the
day help them mitigate the risks that go
along with the sales of alcohol and
tobacco
to our our staffing levels talk about
the sworn Staffing levels first just to
give you a cliff no version of in 2009
our staffing totals were at 26 sworn
members so as we talk about our sworn
members there sworn police officers in
the state of New Hampshire they have
full jurisdiction but we keep them
between the book markers of alcohol and
tobacco enforcement
in 2011 we we
had mandated cuts and we had a reduction
of our Force five positions and and
moving down to 2022 where we are today
or or at the end of the last year we're
at a total of 21 sworn full-time
enforcement investigators in seven
part-time positions we have two openings
at this point civilian Staffing we do
have civilian Staffing also they are
auditor years and we have 12 in 2022 we
have 12 full-time
staff there for part-time and we have
one current opening so when we talk
about the Personnel in the division that
have oversight of the three-prong
approach we are looking at
implementing this to
6718 licensees in this state and out of
state because we have direct shippers
that we have oversight over also with
full time for I'm sorry 15 full-time
investigators with a ratio of
447.8 or almost
448 licensees per investigator
thank you
uh liquor licensees on page 41 uh
license types as this committee well
knows uh we have 52 license types uh
available uh we talk about them quite
often here
um the criteria for each license is
established by Statute
and liquor state liquor rules generally
licenses can be separated into two
categories which great question on
premise where alcohol is sold uh are
consumed on the premise so like Tina
said there'll be restaurant lounge brew
pubs Social Clubs and off-premise where
alcohol can be taken off the premise to
be consumed convenience stores grocery
stores uh retail wine outlets like was
mentioned earlier
moving to page 42 this gives you a
snapshot of where we are or where we
were year end
um with our licenses license types
on-premise uh you can see the numbers
there as it breaks down
um our 6718 license types
our largest is our on-premise uh
off-premise at almost 1500 direct
shippers which are out of state
licensees they're shipping directly into
this state to you the consumer uh we
have 1400 of those manufacturers we have
807 tobacco only which is separate from
a grocery store convenience store which
can sell tobacco also we have 229 and
then our seasonals are
671 and like I said earlier that gives
us our
6718. looking at the revenue
um from our beer tax and permits we're
looking at approximately just over 13
million dollars
liquor license fees uh almost 33
000 uh I'm sorry 3 million 600 just
under 3 million 600 direct shipping uh
almost 2 million
um uh and then down to our overall title
which is just our total is just under 19
million dollars a year
moving on to page 43
so our education ever efforts are huge
and and we keep them very near and dear
to our hearts public awareness and
education
um we have our number one uh requested
uh education platform is our fatal
choices which is an impaired driving
simulator we use
um a two golf carts that we have
obtained through grants with our fatal
vision goggles uh fondly known as drunk
goggles to go to take students of
defensive driving courses
um and uh and driving courses throughout
the state that are in high schools to
teach them what the adverse effects of
driving while impaired are
we figure that uh student parents are
the best teachers of their students and
sometimes our kids need to touch the
stove to see if that that it's hot so
we're giving we'll give them a safe
platform to see that the adverse effects
of drinking alcohol and driving could
create a a fatal situation our community
outreach vehicle we have obtained two
computerized drunk driving simulators
through nabka Grant one of them is
inside of that community outreach
vehicle if you look at it as the
bookmobile
it has a lot of community-based things
on the side of it but inside it gives a
nice view of alcohol awareness
it has an intoxilizer breath machine
inside of it but more more than anything
else it has another drunk driving or
impaired driving simulator inside of it
our buyers beware program
we we doing partnership with the
coalitions throughout the state
where
we have
taken our campaign on public awareness
and bumped it up a notch and we're at
and we're educating adults about the
dangers and consequences of providing
alcohol to minors and and some of you
that heard me talk last week on our
radio show uh with Jack Heath know that
you know this is a huge problem
throughout the state and that's
empowering our kids to consume alcohol
prior to the legal age to do that and
that has happened throughout this day
and we've had negative incidents with it
so we believe that the more awareness
out there and educating our parents
what those negative and adverse effects
are that we can we can combat that
presentations we do so many
presentations and I'll get into that
next uh present or down couple Pages
presentations in schools usually more so
around uh prom and
um uh graduation time
um we we bring our investigator out with
us who is our our mascot
um to talk about the adverse effects of
alcohol
um and and it's really one of those
things that puts a smile on everybody's
face everybody likes to see a mascot
um our one of our greatest Partners the
Fisher Cats we have we're part of their
mascot
um uh competition uh yearly and and it
it does bring a lot of smiles and and a
lot of awareness out to to our
um our citizens of this state on page 44
uh continuation with our education
efforts so that was the public uh
training that we do we also train those
that sell alcohol in this state at every
level so
um the managers uh managers training
seminar is four of all of our owners and
managers throughout the state of that
are licenses so
um and that is mandated by Statute 45
days after they obtain a license they
have to go through this training segment
moving down to our Grocers education
seminar again this is specifically for
Grocers
and clerks
again training them both about
seeing those outward signs of
intoxication that they don't have to
sell to people that are are showing
signs of intoxication but also talking
about IDs and and fictitious IDs because
we do training on fictitious IDs also
um our total education in alcohol
management are for all of our servers
and all of our servers servers
throughout the state do an awesome job
this training is actually given in
person or online all these platforms are
given in both
both venues just to to make it uh easier
for the user to to take this training
whether it's a refresher every year
um or or that they actually want to come
down and and be part of one of our uh
many classes that we put on weekly
moving at page 45
um again uh we're not
separate from anybody else we do the
same training for our liquor and wine
outlets
um and and also our clerks are trained
the very same way that we would train
anybody else and and those outward signs
of intoxication and fictitious
identification again we're trying to
help our licensees we've partnered with
them every day of the week to show them
that we're there to help them mitigate
the risks that are involved in selling
alcohol
uh moving down to our let's training
that's uh more if I can kind of dummy
that down a little bit it's security
training but it's for the bouncers of uh
these establishments again we we in
enforcement feel that on our sworn side
of the house those people that work in
those venues are our first line and and
they're seeing whatever has I hate to
say it but gone sideways and and they
are great partners of ours and and we
just want to make sure we're all on the
same page and again we're looking at
risk and we're helping them mitigate
risk because there is a lot of risk into
that field uh fictitious ID training I
talked about and those Trends change as
much as the IDS that come from overseas
change so
um any time that there is something new
we're on top of it we have National
partners that help us out with that so
we're getting getting state-of-the-art
training
on what are the new trends that we're
seeing in fake IDs
moving to our educate page 46 our
education and awareness here you'll see
the breakdown our licensee training
we've done 63 live classes with 850
students and that second bullet point we
have trained
2870 people via our online so we're
really proud of opening up that online
platform because I think we're getting
out to more people that way
our Liquor Outlet employees again we
give the same training only specific to
their needs 45 live
Lots classes with 343 students
um the second bullet point there 645 had
been trained online through that
platform a total person's trained of
moving to the next column our awareness
events our awareness events in 2022 67
events Statewide with an estimated
attendance of about 113 201
putting the two of them together were
just short of a hundred and twenty
thousand
um
people and that we have reached out and
touched to on a yearly basis on top of
the radio show that we do twice twice a
month uh we're reaching out to anywhere
between 50 and 95 000 people we're
touching a lot of people with our
message in in New Hampshire in the
southern part of New Hampshire uh Maine
I'm sorry southern part of Maine so
those who visit our state those who
reside in our state we want them to to
make good choices serve and drink
responsibly and at the end of the day we
have a safe environment for everybody to
do that in
down below are some pictures of uh our
fatal choices uh golf cart that we one
of them that we use
um the vehicle in the middle is a themed
vehicle for alcohol awareness that we
take to the schools and then
um our investigator is our mascot and uh
along with the governor uh in front of
the State House here and uh that was for
a road race The Rock and Road Race that
we attended
about
thank you Chief so on the last on the
last couple pages are just some of the
awards that the Liquor Commission has
won over the last few years uh you know
we take our accolades seriously uh we're
a business we're an 800 Million Dollar
business we take what we do very
seriously for the state not only for the
revenue but the safe consumption of
alcohol
since 2010 when we started this program
and we started this this branding of the
Liquor Commission we've been very
successful and we really appreciate
everybody's support because without your
support we can't do what we do so thank
you very much and again we'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you I often wondered and I have
been to these events
um the wine tasting events the large
ones and the distilleries
um event it's usually in Manchester I
believe
um there's a lot of alcohol consumption
there so I'm not sure how you regulate
the people that are tasting because I
think a lot of people get drunk there
well we we do it a number of ways
everybody who's serving alcohol there is
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
to serve alcohol so they've all gone
they're all mainly their broker
suppliers and and retailers and we also
have a support team of enforcement at
those events we do have very very little
issues at those events as they go people
are very conscious about you know
drinking and driving for the most part
in general but at those events events
specifically
yeah but we do have that Sip and stay
we have the Sip and stay responsibly so
they get uh they have a discounted room
rate in the in the in the hotel and we
also have uh a limousine company that
offers rides as well
as part of that program
we give credit to that to Lori she's the
backbone behind that I just want to say
one thing I I know that you know when
people run a business of that size no
one runs a business of this size by
themselves we literally have a huge team
of people of 1200 people people in the
stores people in enforcement and people
at headquarters this is a great team of
folks who are sincerely dedicated with
what they do and I personally could not
do it without all their help and
especially the senior team that's here
today so thank you
[Music]
thank you guys very much thank you very
much uh for the committee members before
you all depart uh we have we have
shuffled the deck a little bit
um so you guys will some of you will be
moving back and forth because I just
didn't think it was right to have all
women on one side and Men on the other
side that was totally unintentional I've
been so uh trained in how to make sure I
mix it up between Republicans and
Democrats like that I wasn't paying
attention to the first names only to the
categories of the columns
yeah uh so for next for we're not we
know meet tomorrow we meet Thursday
Thursday no so Thursday is going to be
our first uh hearings
um and one of the things I would hope
you all will think about
um is that we do divide the committee up
into three subcommittees three divisions
so the divisions are insurance
uh which will be both property and
casually and health insurance
um uh liquor
and as you can see that uh
that's obviously the most fun right but
uh we're there by I would have to you
know give notice that there might be a
special task this year
um if if uh if it happens the way it's
supposed to happen
um we would be getting the marijuana
legislation yeah
so that would be going to the liquor
committee uh subdivision and then uh and
last word is what we call business
business and and just all this so if you
look at the Attorney General the
consumer and Banking and condos
and I'm trying to think what else we now
have 27 bills
um so all those would go into the the
the the Third
division third division so think about
which ones you want to be in and then
and then email me and let me know and
we'll be putting that together
um so uh 2017 is pretty light
um they're theoretically probably will
be more com subcommittee uh more bills
coming in and then we'll I'll try to
push through the hearings and get the
hearings done quickly and then we get
into the subcommittees and really thrash
out the bills
um we uh my I absolutely plan to be
taking the vacation week because I
already have my my trip to Virgin Gorda
Virgin Gorda booked hi Mr chairman what
week is that so that is uh theoretically
it's like the first week of March
it's it ends end of February first week
of March it's in uh it's in the calendar
so the last thing I guess I want to make
sure I introduce our committee assistant
who sits in the back and Kristen is uh
Chris and Grant is um he's been doing
this now how many years now three or
three years
and
um and she uh is is is already up to
speed
and uh and then and of course we have a
committee assistant now just so you
understand the roles of these two people
technically
um that you know your Carrie you'll hear
about only with you are making uh the
the motion the majority or minority
motion on a bill and have to write a
blurb
um then you would then she'll she'll be
looking for that uh documentation
Kristen however is technically she is
our committee system but you have to
keep in mind she research excuse me
is that she um is serves four committees
right three three you got three
are you sharing it okay so
um so theoretically if there was a task
that you think this would be great for
her to do some research for you you have
to go through me you have to ask me and
talk to me first and then I will give
give the blessing to have it have it
accomplished
um and but she for No Doubt when we get
into bills certainly there will be bills
that uh we've had before and she'll have
have done the research and you'll get a
memo on on all the things that you know
what the history of that bill and you
know where it is and they've been in
this committee and then of course when
we get into committee conferences she'll
do a side by side if it's necessary but
uh does any anybody else lobbyist you
want to say hello
you did right I mean yeah
okay say goodbye
yeah no I'm standing between you guys
and leaving uh briefly my name is
Brendan Flaherty You Can Count Me among
one of the new faces in the room I just
started at the DuPont group uh working
with uh Jim Monahan and Kate Horgan so
I'm working with them on the bills that
they're tracking in this committee so
pleasure to meet all of you and thank
you Mr chairman for the time great
and it's flarity right Clarity okay
okay uh yeah so just so everybody went I
I am uh sometimes a little old school so
I say things I'm not supposed to say
it's like it's a researcher and that and
anytime I use the word blurb
please just go ahead and say in yourself
he's calling he's talking about the
committee report
because we're not supposed to be called
blurbs
but that's what they always were so
they're always for a blurred but to me
it sometimes is a little hard to get
otherwise
um if you on this the state web page
um my cell phone number is my phone
number
so anytime you want to call me or text
me feel free to do that it's you know
certainly available
um and uh and I hope to get it because
that way I can then put you in my my
contact list so if I need to call you it
would be helpful to have so other than
that I think you know Nina do you have
anything you want to cover you want
anything you want to cover anything you
want
just want to say goodbye okay
yeah I'm talking to you well yeah right
[Music]
um